so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect what's up everybody i am thomas
dopeziolo whatever you want to call me i
am here with my co-host marty o'deal
what's up folks
guys the dope as usual podcast we were
talking about live drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between
hopefully
we don't get censored again because
we've been getting censored lately but
let's leave it at that we'll stay on a
positive note thank you guys so much for
being here and just listening
to us talk about stuff it's really what
this literally what this is so thank you
for joining thank you for being here for
your at home just chill with your homies
thank you for letting us hang out with
you if you're by yourself and you're
just hanging out with us
what's up all right and if you're in the
car your way to work i'm sorry just be
safe
and you'll be home soon all right marty
how you feeling i'm feeling great man
i'm so happy to be here it's monday
rolling to the end of this month
been on a tear oh it's monday in the
episode like marty it is not monday yeah
yeah
you have to be thinking steps ahead yeah
hell yeah we've been on a terror this
past couple weeks so yeah we're doing a
lot anytime we get to come back in here
and just recap and chill and look at the
next couple weeks it's a good time
oh yeah um
yeah sorry i am i i moved yesterday i'm
i'm very tired
but it's fun
good good moves good tired i'm excited
um
yeah sorry i'm all off track yeah we
moved yesterday right guys so
um i'm done i'm gonna smoke in the
hallways of my apartment you want to
talk about the sticky note situation yes
you guys know you guys know if you
follow my snapchat my instagram i've
been getting harassed by my building
telling me three days you need to move
out for the smoking complaints
for the past year for the past year
98 of the time i'm not even in the
building when they serve the papers
because i'm at work
here
they have cameras
excuse me so my lawyer
wrote a very nice
passive aggressive letter to them
and they have left me alone haven't
bugged me once
the other day i finally found out who
has been saying this about me it's not
even the building somebody has to
complain the ability's not
yo he's home put a note on his door it's
not the way it works i finally found out
which
neighbor it was
the younger couple on my floor with the
cool dogs that always say hi and talk to
me in the elevator and they seem super
ah seems super chill
it was them i walked in with my homies
the other day and there's a note on the
floor a sticky note with a slash through
it like how girls write and as soon as
she read it i read it rosie looks like
that's a girl's handwriting like you're
right
it is it was on the floor in front of my
door said no smoking final warning i'm
like bro i just got in the building what
is happening right
and then i go back outside because i'm
packing up i go back outside and throw
something away i mean within 10 seconds
of getting home
and i see the neighbor that neighbor
with her dog like she's like rushing
into her house i was like
i'm not a
criminal do you think i was gonna like
attack you you know me the way she was
looking like
and she got in like huh
i turned around to look like at my home
like would i
did i look like a predator when i came
out what happened i look and the note is
on my door
how long we in here
you know let me just not risk it
this
nice young woman i'll just call her this
nice young lady
took the time to go write a note
sticking on my door like she works there
all right and this part did not tell you
i was so upset
i wanted to go punch your door
and then say hey leave me alone
but that that's redundant it doesn't
work all right
so i wrote a nice note i forgot to tell
you i wrote a nice note
you noted her back wrote a nice sticky
note that i was like you know what let
me uh
i wasn't but do you like me yes or no
because these notes are stupid like why
are you leaving notes on my door you
don't worry you want to send me into a
like murderous rage leave me a sec leave
me a sticky note on my door i was so
furious and i went
and i left it there i went back to her
door and then 10 seconds later i walked
in my house went
i'm a business owner
i'm going to take this note out i went
and took the note and threw it away i
was like you know what
she's not happy with herself enough to
do that uh-huh what's me doing that
gonna help her took down the [__] and
balls you drew on her no i wrote a very
nice polite door and i ended up with you
do not work here
do not leave sticky notes at my door
what are you doing
like i saw her and she looked and then
i've been seeing her every day since i
don't know what happened that's how it
goes but now we're just and i'm i don't
know what she really looks like that way
you got people smoking halloween on your
floor too right yeah it's not even me
i've been dabbing my ass off
if you tell me you've been smelling my
dabs you're a you're a liar
all right and most of the time i'm here
i'm here all day and they always give
the time
that's why my lawyer wrote a letter
like hey
42 they've over 40 times they've given
me a note saying i'm need to move out in
three days if i get another complaint so
when's the next complaint mm-hmm it
doesn't make sense you need like a term
like a cancelable like ism like racism
you said this can capitalize on two
cannabisms
discriminate against weed smokers you
said that we were sweating our asses off
over there
still not here
yeah still not here i'm still hot
even though we're in the ac i'm still
fat and hot um
so yeah this one's what's been going on
i have another month on my lease and
they asked can we show the apartment go
nope don't step foot in my door you wait
till i i give you the keys or i'm gonna
sue you i told him last time walk in my
door i might shoot you in the chest do
you need to knock first
because i don't know who it is and i
don't know who's coming to my door i
might shoot you right then and there
yeah because i told him like stop
opening my door they i don't even
understand my door multiple times my
build office yes
that's insane insane that's insane yeah
that's how you get shot that's how you
get shot in the chest
so but but today they were fixing
something at the new apartment like they
were installing new washer
and the guy like jiggled the handle i'm
like hmm
no you can't do that like i'm new here
but i'm gonna punch you in your mouth if
you walk into my house
unannounced yeah it's on-site it's crazy
because what happens when people get
shot
california law yeah it just makes me
upset mm-hmm that's all i just wanted to
smoke weed
but now you're in a new spot i'm in a
new spot yeah um not too far from the
place out i'm at
baller super fun uh american psycho
penthouse yeah straight up i
shocked the guys looked at me this
morning
but yeah come in and i was like
oh yeah that's right i look like this
you guys are older than me yeah come
into my spot i always forget like
people look at me stupid because like is
your parents home i always forget that
yeah
um but it was cool man att guy came
today hooked it up so my twitch gots the
hard ethernet fiber cables about to be
streaming yeah i'm about to be streaming
i've got all new furniture man i feel
like a straight adult
i got all new furniture it's coming
tomorrow morning
i had my cousin shout out to eye movers
and merced my cousin's adrian
my whole family is moving what was that
cough
i thought it was a cup
yo this hair just in my eye i usually do
my hair guys but i haven't got a haircut
sorry um
yes they moved us i didn't lift a box
nice first time in my life i was like
i'll just pay you
my back hurts
it's so much easier now i get now i'm on
the other side of me moving people
that's amazing oh i've never felt that
so much less stress
yeah yeah i was doing i was working
while they were moving on i was doing
all my computer stuff i'm like you want
dab
take dab
all right and they're moving boxes
because you know because of smokes
so the best movement was his life is
like yeah i was chilling smoking like oh
yeah let me move these boxes because he
has all his homies his workers
helping yeah and his partner damien it
was cool easiest move i ever did in my
life
um yeah i got all new furniture man i'm
so stoked when you come in there did you
get the table up the stairs
it didn't fit in the elevator yeah and
then somehow they walked in the door
with it not a question
but when i got there as a mover
impossible doesn't fit not going to work
unless you break part of it and they got
it in there so whatever
super sick i got a uh i got a pretty
funny neighbor story i was thinking of
on the way up here ironically from from
your your house now no from back and
forth that's the cops yeah no no why are
you losing sort of the cops blowing ball
smoke at their house at 6 18 and then
we're super ironic i don't know many of
them are boys too
many of them are boys too that's when
you know you left and you made it yeah
my cop neighbor
fist bump
barbecue no
no not no more back in the day i
remember i was thinking about how
outlandish this [__] was so we used to
live in a duplex
stop me if i already i might have told
you this in real life i don't remember
we had a run of these neighbors beneath
us is that the peaches and cream no i
know first of all it's which one is it
oh my god it's so [__] good
that's a blueberry coach oh my god
the fact that like that's ours makes me
so happy
[Music]
i know that's like a nice crystal light
like a good way to put it crystal light
but the pizza creams is a pizza yeah
yeah
we could do a whole separate video on
this
we do i'm sure god just did we do
anyway so we had this run of crazy ass
neighbors beneath us and we lived in
this duplex they were kids
the ones i'm getting to kind of were i
mean they were our age we're all like
20.
oh so something else yeah we were right
in this duplex i got i got i could do a
couple hours on crazy neighbor stories i
was thinking about this
uh
so the first neighbors we had we were
always at odds with because they
couldn't figure out how to not park in
the [__] driveway we had the driveway
so constantly i'm getting in [__]
confrontations with these dudes
always ever we got a newborn we're
coming in
always like they're out there this
[__] has a dodge stratus he's
out there washing it in the driveway
like it's a [__] lambo everything
like it's his driveway though yeah it's
a rental and like we were we were there
first [__] we got the driveway like
sorry
you know we got a newborn and [__] so we
were always at odds with these dudes and
then like i checked the dude confront
him about it
and then out here i'm talking [__] the
floors were so thin you could hear right
beneath i'd hear him talking [__] and
i'd go back down and check him again
like [__] you're done you're talking
[__] like what the [__] don't you
understand
and they're you know what i mean like we
had we had those going those then those
people moved out and this couple moved
in white dude yeah white ass i don't
know why i felt like dirt face probably
a white dude a dirt face
dirt face [__] goofy ass white dude
dirt face what does that mean derp like
like oh that's not understanding yeah
they said dirt face that's i was like yo
really
dirty white guy
new term that's that shitty mustache you
get though that's that which you wanna
yeah the josh allen exactly joshua's
what i'm saying he's keeping it [__]
authentic with that shitty little
mustache he's got
the josh allen and the thin gold chain
on the white team the wife beat her and
[__] yeah oh
so a bunch of dudes
i'm sorry man i'm sorry
[Laughter]
uh
we had this couple moving beneath us
so it's just the same demo as me and
april it's the dude the his girl and the
daughter
by demographic
that's what you meant by it i was like
demo uh-huh i keep going i don't get it
so we were like happy to have an actual
couple with a kid move in but turns out
this bit the girl is crazy the girl is
like screaming at this dude at all times
me and april would be like laying in the
bath together chilling like it was like
a hobby of ours we listened to like yo
stupid [__] boom slam some [__]
all day every day she's just on this
dude always like domestically and it's
like a joke between us like domestically
so two big incidents that i was thinking
about that were funny that stood out
did i tell you about the about the the
front yard incident with this kid
i don't think so me and april are
sitting on the front on the upper porch
like smoking a blunt [__] april's
sitting with me we're looking out over
the whole neighborhood this is on south
side or south south park ave in buffalo
south buffalo uh just looking over the
neighborhood and we were deep on the
porch so like we could watch always what
was going on and like not necessarily be
all you know i mean you can't really see
us out there
so we hear them starting to get into a
fight beneath us and it spills out into
the front yard and then
she leaves with her friend and takes off
and the dude gets in
his car
and like takes off behind him and her
car still parked on the street she took
off with her friend
and they had gotten in this big argument
the front lawn we're out there just
chuckling and [__] this is just normal
so then we see him come back down in his
car he's got this dude's got like a
little gray like [__] cavalier or
some [__] his [__] has got a buick
something a little bit bigger i see him
from the stop sign down the street
comes flying down the street bam smashes
him into the front of her car
right in front of the house and [__]
his [__] up
i know it sounds crazy
it sounds crazy he comes flying down the
street slams into her car that's parked
she's not even there but it's like both
of theirs it's bull fares
and he like knocks the [__] bumper
off his car let's keep it at my house
though
no wait
did he go to jail so then
it's not over he [__] up his car he
literally got out picked his [__] up
parked the car and then proceeded to
pull out all their furniture out of the
lawn so he's coming out with the couch
he's coming out with the sofa he's
coming out everything's on the [__]
lawn now we're all just we're sitting up
here just laughing at the [__]
and then she comes home
and then they have a big ass
confrontation in the front yard again
where's the kid
i don't know where the kid is
the kid's not with them for this one
then the one i'm about to tell you about
the kid is very much with them
and then she [__] makes him pull all
the [__] back in the house
watched him drag all his [__] back in
the house
and that was that now shortly thereafter
we're having our uh
baby shower okay
we're having our baby shower so i think
i switched them around this maybe they
were before
the dirt face white dudes because we had
ariana at the dirt face white dudes they
must have been before them because
i remember april was having her baby
shower we had all of her family upstairs
all of her friends they're all dressed
nicely none me my boys are in the attic
we're like shunned from the party
and uh
i hear them pull up
and like
as everybody from the baby shower is
leaving they get into a fight in the
driveway you got to walk past their car
to like get out now you know i mean they
pulled in the driveway
the dudes got his daughter in his arms
like my literally my mother-in-law's
leaving as this is happening people from
the april's baby shower are leaving he's
getting out of the car she's driving
he's got his daughter in his hands and
he just reaches in and blasts his [__]
in the face
two three four
yeah while he's holding his daughter
blast this [__] that's why we get
age-restricted to that you blast this
[__] in the face i believe that we
gotta
don't bleep it leave it in
[__] you
and i'm sorry to say i almost cheered
for this fool for a second like she
missed trenchable moment he finally won
yeah he did but he but
oh my god
my
sisters were like 13 mortified in this
[__]
the party was leaving as this was
happening yeah why do you wait for the
crowd they pulled up
they pulled up and got out of there he
was just it was just business
yeah it was happening did you drugs the
drink oh i'm sure probably yeah of
course speakers no i don't know about no
tweakers isn't it
is i mean no there i don't remember them
being up all night there it was just
daily [__] freak outs
those were the two big moments that
stand out
and uh something happened after that i
remember they were they weren't around
much longer after
after that situation with him blaster in
the face couple clean shots
yeah a couple clean shots while holding
a kid
out of the car the kids out of the car
she's sitting in the car so he's
reaching in the car with a clean so what
happened did she punch him back no
no she that was like his vengeance mom
that was it that was it like
my april's mom was there and [__] like
everybody was like shouting and [__]
like it was like an orbit at the
incident like oh
eddie murphy you get picked on by your
wife forever
oh okay well you finally won except this
is domestic violence now you're going to
jail [__]
from detroit
i'm not saying a choice for domestic
violence people
my bad that's how i'm saying i'm saying
not an orbit hardcore norbit
orbit from the hood
from the get i do not miss that [__]
that type of joke you know it's sad
when you said blast this [__] in the
first hand i was like
damn my dad just punched my mom oh
that's sad that's the first thing i
thought was like
yeah god oh
damn i can't see myself getting to the
point of hitting my girlfriend and then
going we're living together after this
still like what the [__]
you don't chill with the dude you beat
up at school you're gonna live with a
girl you beat that's crazy to me and
that's a deleted that's age restricted
and that's why we were in trouble
all the time
but it's all right yeah i mean this is
just a gentle story about this is a
gentle story about neighbors
live life and incidents you've seen
color purple that one oscars yeah how
come we're getting aged
that hurt my soul what if we have danny
glover on are we okay
[__]
yo
i i swear to god if you were on youtube
and you came across
me and you and then you got in and he
has a baby in hand and he's just
blasting this [__] in the face
clean shots oh no
that's not gonna fly dude
i didn't think about that it's it's the
whole drive up here i'm thinking like
i'm gonna keep this [__] clean today
yeah like
no it's just not gonna happen i don't
know we're playing this game with
youtube where we're just like hoping we
don't trying just for the sake of the
views and [__] yeah we're gonna get paid
we stopped monetizing our videos because
we started getting restricted so much
shout out to dj ghost for some youtube
tips
it worked still getting [__] played
though we're still non-stop smoking pens
what are we at
these are great 20. these are great yeah
but yeah got a cool little announcement
over here you ready
so you guys know chavo you guys know our
homie show i'll take that one
you know our homie shabo system of a
down north kingsley 22 red
he hits me and marty up and says yo we
got a special uh gift for you guys
so they sandblasted
sandblasted the dope as usual logo with
the 22 red all over it and filled it
we're not getting too much trouble
this one with prop the sherb yeah with
prop herb
he filmed it with proper
let's go
the sherb lotto from 22 all right from
22 we love 22 red because they represent
the artists
they go hard they go hard with all the
artists that's not like there's a lot of
people out there i own a weed bread
chavo lives this [__] like it is his
personal true company
everything you smoke he smokes that's
the way to put it
this one's called literally so delicious
that's what the name of it is how did
you notice that smells
ugh
like
like a funk mixed with green juice
like clean
like a health drink but funky at the end
it's beautiful so
here we go shout out to shabo he said yo
keep these jars in your studio whenever
you run out we'll just fill it up so now
that's what you're smoking on the show
and i go thanks man
so shout out to the show with the un
unofficial weed sponsors so we're going
to be smoking this is just going good 22
right yeah thank you thank you for that
we don't want to get too much trouble we
just wanted to say thanks and these jars
[__] awesome so sick like they're
they're so sick to see our logo on
something it's weird huh i love to see
our logos next to
others yeah like yeah oh of course it's
like a collaboration without a
collaboration yeah
it's too [__] cool with that being
said
i got you
so delicious to share blotto first
you pick hold on i want to make an
informed decision all right all right
here we go while marty's doing that i'm
going to teach you guys english
synonyms
i think i don't know this is cool
so delicious looking i know literally
the name i got an alfalfa going i don't
even know guys my hair is just so [__]
i'm sorry i'll go with you so delicious
all right that's what i had first too
can we talk about the bill's third
string beating the [__] out of the
cult's first string this past week hey
man i didn't watch football i was i was
busy
i missed all football i just know the
packers lost to the [__] niners damn
all i know
oh that was like wednesday or some [__]
that's all i know all right i know the
raiders won and you told me the bill's
one our second string quarterback got in
there it's his time to shine and [__]
throws two picks
gets involved in a [__] fumble
and then the third string qb comes in i
think this [__] threw one
incomplete pass the whole time yes
just lasers connections connections him
and uh i forget the [__]
black shield or something the receiver
it was like it was like black shield
something like that black spear black
shield some [__] uh sure
yeah
black shield i think so black i don't
[__] remember the dude's names the
third string wide receiver but they were
black shield blackspear
i don't think these are real last names
man i don't think that's what happened
yeah his last name johnson
yeah
i had a funny idea for a bit that we
decided it was cancelable based off the
bills names but
no money
i think it's funny
people with sense of humors will laugh
yeah
youtube will not like that
they won't like that and until we're in
position to go hey
it doesn't matter about that no more
yeah we're coming up with some funny
bits folks all right i have about 400
things in my phone 398 of them i will be
cancelled
not by people i care about like i don't
care the fans aren't going to cancel
they go yo thomas that was pretty
[__] funny yeah yeah i know
i know but there's one in my tip of my
tongue i want to yell so bad and
screaming in the mic but i'll get in
trouble and it's about mexicans and i'm
mexican but you know i'll get in trouble
can we talk about how that dj ghost
episode was and how epic that wasn't
just how that was that was tight biggest
uh view episode in one week ever too
not even what a great episode too
even the youtube was like yeah okay cool
all right good we'll let you guys get
views this is non-non-cancelable
it was nothing but good [__] yeah like
that's every episode yeah that's how i
feel like a lot of our episodes sorry
i'm over here [__] my hair up so much
my bad my bad my bed
i over here look like lord farquaad from
track and [__] my bad guys
on uh let's go the vibes going on
my man you see it you see the split i
[__] hate it
[__] hate like dave navarro jonathan
taylor thomas hey man i would strive to
be that's what i'm saying
bring it back thank you john and taylor
thomas hey dad
remember when they killed him off
on what on home improvement stop what
you're saying
[Laughter]
right what do you mean killed him off
with cancer some [__] i remember
look us up right now you're telling me
they ended home improvement with one of
the sons dying i think so i think your
memory is [__]
if not
i'm sad
they killed him
remember the one where brad smokes weed
on the phone yeah i guess it will be
smoking weed for a while and they hang
up for a while brad this is drugs like
brad why would you make that call in
your kitchen first off the [__] oh they
killed the mom off
she died
in the show we're going here we're
freestyling here off top so marty's just
making [__] up guys anybody just made
some [__] up right now
somebody got killed off my mind it was
jonathan taylor thomas you remember
family matters for steve urkel begged
laura no
no it never happened no i'm pretty sure
it did
this is [__]
what happened where are we at with this
i don't know where are we at go oh
what's up with some fan questions i just
had to ask where we were oh [__]
bringing it back bringing it back guys
oh also
for everyone out there that likes puss
trees go to pushtrees.com you know the
homies for life the blunt and the
lighter our number one selling shirt of
all time
[Music]
just made the new version guys here we
go
oh that was hard
right
yeah that was sick that's how it felt
too
as soon as i did this i went
in my head i love it
the homies for life but the joint
version just released all right it
released uh this weekend so if you're
watching this episode it's
should be in stock go to pushtrees.com
appreciate you guys if you're getting
that [__] anywhere else it's a bootleg
yes i see him on amazon [__] amazon
all right [__] that who's the old lady
no it's she's she's nice she wears a
shirt because she thought it was awesome
which is awesome yeah yeah yeah but
she's getting from amazon because
doesn't have my stickers on it
how can amazon just reproduce my [__]
with my logos on it it has buzz trees
logos on and they're selling it seasoned
assist my lawyers they just don't
respond
that's what i'm gonna do if i ever get
sued i'm just gonna pretend that it
didn't happen just like amazon does
[__] you
and questions all right every time well
not every time every time i come in the
kitchen you in the kitchen
all my food 510. what's a party you'll
never forget so you're going right into
it sir i was [__] quoting john
witherspoon over here
what
cheeky510 says what's a party you'll
never forget
i mean the best ones i don't remember
hmm
did you go to a lot of parties in high
school
stupid question a lot
yeah sold weed oh yeah yeah that's like
yeah one year oh yeah
the picture i posted today that was me
prime that that shirt
that's the shirt i kept telling you guys
about story time the green striped shirt
i wore my [__] that's the exact me
that i'm talking about yeah
you found photos you had never of
yourself never even seen because i was
on face i finally made a facebook under
my real name
and i saw people that i haven't seen
since high school i'm like yo
you have children holy [__]
and i'm going through this girl melissa
i usually hang out they're going through
a page and i see a picture of us
i'm like yo when did you take i don't
even never even seen these pictures in
my life that was pretty cool facebook's
good for that weird other than that i'm
out i'm out i don't want to see you you
bitching
facebook is like a place where
everyone's like
you know how i feel about that here
like i don't give a [__] yeah that's why
i don't make facebook that's all these
things petition now like a petition
that ain't gonna do [__] [__] get
outside and help
i don't get it too into it because then
people are gonna know who i'm talking
about this they're from my town but i'll
just leave it at this specific yeah i
don't want to do specific i don't really
care but you know
um
fan questions the party i'll never
forget
i blacked out most of it i think i've
done a story time on it i'm pretty sure
i've done if i haven't i am [__]
up
um
i would do a mansion party once and
that's the most epic one ever when do a
manager party almost dropped a 40 from
the balcony on a girl's head what if she
would have died
almost dropped my 40 on her head
i went down my friend mohit was giving
these white girls shots of budweiser
in shot glasses
he went who wants a shot of beer and
these girls all ran up like he was
giving away [__]
weed
a shot of beer okay
who wants me to blow smoke in your face
i'll go smoke in your direction who's
trying to get [__] up that's the
equivalent of a shot over here like what
the [__]
um
then we left and when we left uh my
homie joe got arrested with my phone
first video i ever took of weed is me
smoking a blunt
in my homie ryan's garage i'm like 15
years old a little me smoking blood
somebody out there's got the phone you
videoed it at 15. yeah i was scared too
like yo my mom i go through my phone but
i needed the video i'm like wow we have
a phone with a video
i'm gonna take a picture a video of me
smoking blood in the garage like that
i'm looking at my friend joe it's like
little meat and then that phone got
taken by the cops so i'm over here
[__] stressed and thinking that the
cops got they're like they're gonna bust
me they know it you know why did he get
taken by the cops because he was walking
on the street from the party and they
told him to start leaving the party
until the cop [__] you
why
she told you to leave just leave
so
that's the party
i tried to get that phone back for like
three weeks in a row the cop told me
meet me here meet me here meet me here
this girl talina this girl i went to
school with it was her older sister was
the cop
she looked through my phone for sure she
looked to it
never got it back i missed the last
pickup the last time she said i'll beat
you right now with [__] face drunk and
my friend nathan's and i went i am not
meeting a cop on her [__]
shift to get my phone wreaking like
alcohol at 50. not happening do you puke
off being drunk a lot i didn't
drink a lot
i can just hold my liquor really well
the way i smoke weeds away a drink i
could drink like a fifth and be like
thomas you [__] up i'm pretty [__]
up
but i mean like i'm shit-faced yeah i'll
be like
i know when you're drunk i have a
picture of it there's more
marty turns into the uh into the the
logo of the guy from mad madness oh [__]
that's how you looked there's one video
there's a rage april facetime me
and i answered what's up marty april
what's up and she's look at your friend
and here in the back is [__] [__] i'm
trying to get her to smoke weed but she
won't smoke weed
yeah i know when you're drunk i'll be
the average person can't really tell but
i'm saying out of nowhere too though oh
really
it's happening three or four times yeah
never really three or four that's it
i have thrown up a hundred times oh okay
i was thinking that's five times
lifetime oh no i've thrown up so much in
my life are you getting me off drinking
yeah
and i've i've kind of reached one
hangover oh i've had like 50.
i get up in the morning if i drink i'll
get up in the morning and be productive
as [__] it's six i'm clean if i go to
sleep drunk at like four i wake up by
like seven eight i've never been more
productive i don't know what it's like a
restart in my brain i don't know what it
is i hate it but it it does work
um so yeah that's the party
you have another question
uh i'm gonna have to look i got i posted
on my instagram like probably two weeks
ago i got [__] so like
so many questions
but i would say for me it was gonna be
oh yeah the party bad [__] no i was just
gonna uh i was thinking
the couple times that i have thrown up
were because april's ma just starts
randomly like drink this drink that
drink this that makes all kinds of mix
your mom drink wine a lot
no no they drink like a jack
yeah that's the older one that's like
the lady the older couple that gets [__]
faced together they get [__] up but
they're seasoned they can drink two
fists and be like marty you're up you're
throwing up
yeah as i have as you know his parents
saw the comfort and [__] but oh they're
they drank yeah she was switching up on
me and i almost puked all over her and
the person next to her
oh yeah i just i
weaved right at the right time because
i'll just be normal talking like this
and then
like at the hooker hotel just like that
exactly like that no at a hotel with
hookers not a hooker hotel
you sounded crazy right now yeah with
your wife uh-huh no banging it's almost
been a year go back to the marty episode
yeah go back to the marty episode if you
want to hear that story that one was the
hooker hotel can't say that way don't
say it that way it's on the clips
channel that's one of my favorite ones
hey everybody driving be real safe
look over here stop right look over your
shoulder when you change lane stop just
replying on your [__] mirror
dicks everybody always almost almost
hits me on the freeway
i do this 87 times the [__] drive no
matter how annoying it is check your
[__] shoulders i mean yeah do that
constantly
every time like my friends or rosie has
her friends like the girls in the back
every time there's a girl in the back
and it's not rosie i have to tell them
first
yo i'm not staring at you
i stare at i look right at the back
right head seat head rest because that's
when i can see everything around me i go
like that bam but it looks like i'm
staring right in your eyes like driving
like
staring at you like i would feel weird
too so i always have to tell people my
back yo i'm not staring at you
i just don't want to die
i feel that i do that even with the
little sensors on the [__] i can't not
drive like that i don't like it i can't
do it oh yeah but the reason i said that
is because i don't want
people feeling weird if i'm just staring
at you 40 times
uh
let me throw this something random at
you real quick
i've been listening to a new book that i
think i told you about uh jennifer myers
from venus oh yeah let me just describe
this plot to you because it's
it's kind of an interesting plot
anybody that's uh in a relationship i
would recommend probably listening to
this book
um for help
no just do you have an astronaut
are you reaching out you have one too i
don't i don't know oh yeah i just don't
want
i felt kind of bad it's like behind the
[__]
yeah i don't know i'm trying to listen
to more books great yeah no this is
[__] forgot to say this is smoking
really yeah no this is delicious it
tastes like a [__] vape pan down
there like it tastes like an actual
candy
psyche gone whatever women are so in the
solar system
you got from the sun
venus earth mars
okay
so the plot of the story is
men are a species that are originated on
mars not not to be taken literally men
are species that originated on mars
women are a species that originated a
separate species that originated on
venus okay
the cavemen of mars with their
telescopes and stuff noticed the women
on venus
and they came together on earth which is
in the middle
to to live life on earth are you saying
caveman had telescopes looking at
[__] and [__]
in the context of this plot okay i'll
say you know they're cavemen right it's
you know what it's not like it's not to
be taken literally sorry i did right now
i was thinking
yeah yeah yeah it's cool it's like some
sci-fi [__] to imagine but the way that
little hair dudes yeah exactly yeah yeah
they're all shredded and [__] they're
doing their weed push-ups and [__]
so then the
but the point of that is
is that it's trying to highlight
how inherently different
almost as if men and women are like
different species
in how they communicate
uh to try to understand to have that
understanding
so if you have communication problems
like in your relationship it's like to
give you an understanding of like you
guys are completely different to begin
with so you got to work with it
yeah and you need to understand like
this person's baseline of
i don't know it's just in terms of how
we communicate no it's true like my mom
like there's she's got to remember when
i was young i'm like she's a dick
get over it don't talk to her and if you
want doctors don't then get over it and
work around that's how she is
always
not true she's not a dick anymore but
that sense of you have to like just
accept it and go how can we make the
best of what it is instead of trying to
make it perfect
is that kind of the communication thing
you're talking yeah or even just like
one of the big things for me that it
just kind of like rang true was like
women
uh communicate women communicate to
connect
that like they want to talk to be heard
and talk
talking about their problems makes them
feel better about their problems whereas
men are more like
not they won't talk about their problems
and if you talk to us about your
problems we want to give you a solution
you know what you mean like i'm sitting
here trying to figure out a solution to
your problems of course the [__]
and that
but that's not necessarily what women
might necessarily even be looking for
they want to just
just want to talk get out yeah yeah i
get it and it's like even just something
as simple as like that's just an
inherent thing amongst most men and
women
that you know
men inherently may not want to be so
expressive about
their problems and that doesn't
necessarily make you
weird or like uh
you know a super quiet person but it
might just be my boyfriend doesn't
communicate well he's just a quiet
[__] likes person's feelings
get over it [__] you know what you got
into
the book i thought he would change yeah
why did you think that mm-hmm
yeah they were like happy with
themselves before they met you what the
[__] wrong with you
yeah i could stop a lot of relationships
problems with like i might say [__] and
dummy a couple of times yeah you got to
understand what we don't understand
[__] yeah don't be a dummy yeah yeah
good for guys and girls uh-huh the women
from mars we i mean
women were from venus when men from mars
i've heard that the book that's the
oldest chicken noodle soup for the soul
yeah like that yeah but i don't know i
want to start doing breakdowns on things
and
try to mix in a couple books and stuff
but it just helped me
it's like just some like real baseline
stuff just a different way of thinking
about it especially if you've been in a
relationship for a long time in the
comments there's people in the comments
yeah yeah through [__] and you know it
might help man yeah for damn sure
because i think it's one of those things
like there's a couple books out there
that i feel like should just kind of be
like required
for life
like uh the secret think and grow rich
those type of books like fundamental
stuff that kids should kind of know i
get what you're saying
it should be in the cream of school yeah
i was gonna be honest man when you were
naming off books i was trying to say
something dumb i've only read like three
books i couldn't say a dumb book because
all the books i like are cool yeah so
like you know she read this and that i
was gonna say something dumb like damn
thomas i searched my whole criteria
and found no other books and just like
what about movie adaptations of books
foundations does that work
i'm dumb
yeah
i have to listen to books i can't sit
there and read one i'll fall asleep
that's out of media hold on a second
yeah
the feel of paper
[Music]
and being alive is sleep it's like oh
[__] i'm dead
do you remember trying to read books in
school and watching kids during the same
silent reading you mean you mean fall
asleep time yeah
my eyes are immediately watering over
yeah and like this instant but i have
insomnia so i always thought i was told
rosie should i start trying to read in
bed i tried for a little bit it didn't
work
isn't that [__] up yeah
yeah
i don't know i feel like it's [__] up
to say but i like i don't think i'll
ever be able to read like that like
long form reading i gotta listen
it's not happening
road signs quick text
no paragraphs yeah i don't know i might
be done for life i never thought about
that you know my for that quest my only
advice
for anybody in relationship and anybody
having problems in a relationship
you can be wrong
you're allowed to be wrong just admit it
i when i'm wrong i say oh [__] i'm wrong
my bad erase that back up you're right
even if it takes a couple days i lo oh
i'm i'm immediate bro like you said you
solve [__] i can solve your problems
yeah just listen
let's do it and the other big thing i
think is like
if you're you're going to argue there's
going to be issues throughout your
relationship but you can never
one thing me and april have never done
you can never disrespect each other you
can never say
mean nasty hurtful [__]
in an argument just for the sake of it
like i think that
that will lead across my mind resentment
i mean but people argue like that's just
a mean person yeah and that's why your
mom don't like you
oh my god
the [__] wrong with you [__] yeah
yeah i would never do that whereas you
would never do that either yeah that's
why we're friends that's why we're still
together yeah [__] i would never want to
do that i would never say some [__] like
we missed a turn like
yeah and that's why in high school you
[__] what the [__] you [__] up and
go to college or something stupid yeah
because i have homie to tell me [__] i'm
like
she said why
that's mean you're still there
i would have an apartment already you're
crazy that's one thing i will never do
and you guys should think this too
not everyone's supposed to be in your
life forever it's okay
if in 10 years you go oh my god i was
with that person for five years i forgot
that they existed for a couple months
holy [__] that's all right you're
allowed to i know some people are still
with people just because they've been
together so long even though it's a
horrible [__] relationship
i don't know i've seen it my thing is
to communicate it's more of this is how
me and rosie get along so well
say what the [__] you're thinking
don't be
stupid it's not easy for a lot of dudes
i don't think
no in an argument by yelp you're right i
am wrong i could try to do that and the
thing is i always do this when there's
an argument and i go this is a
misunderstanding why are we arguing
i'll go you said this i said this
where's the problem
well oh oh i thought you said something
else and that's how i solved my [__]
problems with
me rosie are you of course we were
[__] couple
but i was going like i always do this
like i said this you said this what the
[__] happened i always do that connect
the dots like where did we go wrong why
are we arguing right now i've done that
every time and we go oh
i'll pull i'll pull the [__] security
footage on you oh no no it's never like
i'm right it's always like
hey man all you gotta do is tell me that
from the beginning give me all the
information because the only thing i
have is the information you gave me so
the reason i'm getting mad is because
you didn't tell me this if you would
have told me that i'm like yeah this
makes sense
of course let's go
that's the main thing just say what the
[__] you're thinking right now it's okay
to break it down like a math problem
like yo what'd you say why am i mad at
you well you said this well i didn't
mean to sound like that oh my bad dude i
thought you're being a [__] dick
done
ninety percent of people's problems are
misunderstandings or them feeling like
why'd you say a [__] like that the
[__] wrong with you what did i do like
i'm sorry dude i was [__] out of
breath i'm sucking it real quick yeah
yeah i was coughing or i tell you 90 of
arguments are crazy bad just like the
one you just said
my mom and dad what was their solve
let's [__] punch each other right in
the mouth
dumb don't do that so if you're in that
relationship remember it doesn't have to
be permanent [__] that it's worth it
there is a ton of value in working and
you know like one of the things the book
talks about is like
the women want to work want they're
trying to basically mold you to be the
best version of yourself you can be like
they want to mold they want they're
always like helping you to try to be
your optimal self which is always i've
always known that to be true with april
but it's like
that can you can also like take offense
to that you can
you know you can
be defensive about that
but you can also
put your ego down and realize that
they actually want what's best for you
and they're trying to push you towards
that [__] yeah
that's what saved my life i feel like
maybe that's being dramatic but
having
her standards to hold myself up to
was what kept me like a nice clean
person after we met
gotcha
no that's true
my thing is always this
because a lot of people ask like yo you
guys been together you guys never broke
up or did this or cheated on each other
like no what the [__]
i would not be here this is the way i
always think of it
when i die and i'm old
and we're both getting judged they're
going to go hey here's a list of the
[__] that thomas did real bad you want
to watch it
i can't even have that on me that's why
i don't do nothing stupid
like why would you want something like
that was heartbreaking
you know what i mean like this [__] up
now you would never [__] [__] over
your homie
and your
partner your relationship whoever you're
with should be your [__] friend
like i want to chill with rosie over
anybody and you ever
all the time
like what the [__] why wouldn't i
i guess it's a lot of people like well
it's not that easy like no it is
[__] you might just be with the
wrong person
and it's okay what does this turn into
hey dr phil come on here let me school
your ass because sometimes you're biased
on that show sometimes you just like
well no you did this but me i can be
like no you're you're fine you [__] up
that's why a lot of my homie i won't say
your name is [__] but i know you
watch like my homies when he's fighting
his wife you know you're talking about
like no you're wrong not fool it's like
this like you are wrong
i love telling my friends like no
you're wrong say it again we just
watched a movie pretend that wasn't you
that guy's a dick huh oh [__] all right
yeah i guess but no she was bugging me
like
if this is a movie are you a dick that's
my thing always saying are you the bad
person in this movie
what do you want me to say
if there was an audience and your
grandma was here would you do the same
things no then you're [__] bad
that's how i try to live dude except for
me and rosie and we're at strip clubs
and [__] i don't think about that or we
weren't doing cool stuff i'm like well
what i do is my grandma was here like no
my gran would never step foot in here
over the bar i'm getting high or
doing something stupid or explicit i
don't think like that but when i'm like
doing stuff yeah
interacting with humans like i could
have told that [__] in my hallway hey
[__] don't ever [__] put a note on
my door again
why would i do that
her boyfriend's super nice then i got to
put him in a position to get his ass
beat by talking to me stupid
you know it's not fair to him
yeah like it's not his fault it's his
stupid [__] girlfriend's fault he got
a sick ass dog
it's not the dog's fault because that
dog attacks me for yelling at this i'm
gonna [__] kill it
there's so many things that can happen
there's so many things i would beat the
[__] out of so many more people if i
didn't if i knew that it ends there
you know that's why i'm so nice like
dude you know what's gonna happen if i
do that his brother's gonna do that and
then i'm gonna have to [__] kill him
yeah there's just no way to get out of
it so why not just be nice let it go and
just try to be successful that's why i
thought like that lady must be real
miserable putting [__] sticky notes
my door at 10 30 at night yeah
it's true it's sad she must be sad maybe
something's wrong
i don't give a [__] if she was cool that
would help but i don't give a [__] [__]
do you think
relationships
that relationship sucks
i'll say that that hallway neighbor
he's not stoked because he always looks
super stoked but he might not be behind
that door
man if she's uh she's leaving his ass
[__] notes around the house
on his body you used to do that
post-its yeah that's why you said that
earlier yeah
your dad's a non-confrontational person
yeah
well he didn't want to we barely [__]
spoke so he would literally like even
know about like you know like domestic
[__] like uh please clean up this yeah
exactly a sticky
oh hell no i'll just tell you but yo
stop that yeah oh i don't know what it
is about music
give me a note [__]
i ain't gonna play guitar and do shimmer
rap
like a poster turned me into a rapper my
dad told me turn that music down
and that was it is that what happened
kind of
man i went got his guitar actually this
week oh that's right you got all your
stuff yeah it was that was a big thing i
guess i got all my mom's belongings
got her ashes got his guitar all the
stuff that from her house oh [__] that
was this damn that was i've been busy
yeah that felt like weeks ago man
so we started going through it and
shadows it's [__] weird you find
anything cool yeah childhood well i
haven't gone through all the pictures
and stuff yet but like my daughters are
like uh emery is like playing his guitar
and like they're all trying out my
homage jewelry and [__] so
you know it's been awesome
it's
nice i can really like i said i think to
i don't know at some point but i just i
feel like a chapter ending right now and
a new one like
beginning right now
between the podcast and just everything
how we're just kind of leveling up with
the dopest and the yola and just
everything's kind of leveling up i feel
like i'm kind of coming to a little
just
end of a chapter and everything i've
been going through this past [__]
year but that's what
nice little segue
massive action august 25th thursday
dropping yeah that's what i wanted that
project to represent because this has
been like the best times the worst of
times
i've got i've achieved things in this
past year i worked my whole life for and
i've went through drama that i wouldn't
wish on anybody so i want that i want
that contrast and this album that's what
i was going for i want to highlight that
success and at the same time you might
see that success you never know what and
i mean what people got going on so
august 25th spotify for sure hopefully
it'll be live on apple and youtube and
all that [__] by that point if not
shortly thereafter
drasticgraphics.com music check that
[__] out
how many are on it
three tracks three and then so basically
where can everybody find it on youtube
we're gonna find it on on because people
are looking up your name and finding on
youtube but they're looking at drastic
graphics and finding just your drastic
graphics youtube page
so
your music is going to be released as
drastic graphics it's going to be on the
drastic graphics there's a section on
the dress graphics youtube channel for
music yeah but for
you spotify how am i going to find you
not trust graphics not stoic anymore no
it's all drastic okay it's a verified
artist
shout out to spotify for that yeah
she had to spotify for that wouldn't
even ask yeah didn't even ask yep they
just verified marty
verified artist
i circled back to people i worked with
and
you know the artwork's done i did a
little music video a little 30 second
little snippet i added it this morning
oh you didn't tell me that yeah who
filmed it
we filmed it uh i already phoned it
while we were recording yeah the whole
thing is sick
oh the whole day yeah
only 30 seconds yeah i'm just gonna put
out it's just gonna be a little snippet
all right so we'll see it's just for fun
it's just for the fans people that want
it get some [__] off my chest i know we
went from what three months ago you
saying yeah maybe i'll drop a link to my
music on youtube
hey on my birthday man i'm dropping some
new [__] i decided um
this kind of like goes back to what i
was talking about like when april went
to new york i was just
uh she took the kids back to new york
for their trip and i was just home alone
for like three weeks and i was going
through heavy duty [__] [__] like
surrounding like my mom's passing and
all her stuff and her ashes and like my
family like
and uh just a a bunch of other [__] too
and it just was like the perfect storm
for this music
where i don't know i just
the songs that i wrote really just me
sitting down one time bam it's written
going in the next day bam it's recorded
45 minutes an hour just getting this
[__] off my chest
you know and it was really nice being
able to vibe out with omar just going
there so nice and smooth and easy and
fun
and uh i got my boy chris who made the
bees from philly shout out to him we'll
see his link on the artwork and my man
t-man
who's mixing it right now we're supposed
to be getting our masters back today
so
where's he from buffalo yeah
yeah we were laughing man i was telling
you we had a really i hadn't talked to
him since it's been like eight years
since we talked but he was my engineer
yeah i recorded hundreds of songs with t
we never exchanged dollar we always just
traded i'll trade him graphics every
time straight up every week we did this
[__] and t sound was better than the big
studios literally the little
closet studio deep deep on [__]
newberg and delavan
hagen on the east side going over there
gunshots going off and [__] coming
through on the mic like it was so real
over there we were at it i loved it the
energy we had we were a team
and um
he always had the best mixes when i came
to the ski lodge and recorded with nick
hogan in them
brought the mixes back to him oh [__]
yeah we finished the songs in his uh
in his studio at his house so and which
brings me to another point
if you listen to california campaign
my last cd i put out uh there was only
one other person i featured on that
mikey b
mikey was the dude that moved out here
with us
um initially back yeah so we got a
three-month airbnb when we first moved
to california and he him and his girl
were with us in the house
he was like 19.
and he's on 59.50 he's on a track called
look at me now
he's on uh
he's on three tracks on the california
campaign but he's fighting for his life
right now he was in a really horrible
motorcycle
yeah so it was just ironic talking to t
putting this music out and just i know
i'm i really really know his family
and uh yeah so i just want to send a
shout out to him because you know i
think he's really going through it
pretty bad right now and his whole
family i'm really super tied in with all
them but uh yeah it's just been it's
just been nostalgic putting together
this music and collaborating with
everybody that i used to work with and
i'm really excited for the fans to hear
it
categories unlike anyone
double back to rap because they need the
story stop struggle let them see the
glory that's why i'm taxing like i
should be living this life like i knew i
would be seeing me all set next to molly
[Music]
sick august 25th all right stay tuned on
drastic graphics instagram twitter oh no
it's marty did it marty made it
yeah he changed his twitter to marty
made it in case you think you unfollowed
marty it's not drastic graphics anymore
yeah martial i wanted to switch it up a
little bit yeah it's it's hard so make
sure not posting any real graphics on
there yeah
on there
it's okay
um so the 25th guys marty's dropping it
all right turning 36
dropping this [__] 36
you're twilight zone age
okay every dude on twilight zone john
smith age 36 oh [__] works at office
building
michael something age 36 in the year of
his 36th or life
in his life in the year of his 36
michael does that oh man twilight zone's
[__] hard where he smokes weed on the
pipe
age age 36 marty walks into his garage
to see his daughter
what's this
finds his bag
no i could barely find my [__] shirt
i'm gonna hide my [__]
[Music]
yeah no i know i'm [__] stupid with
it i got lockable things like he's
kidding he's got so much space
yeah no nobody's getting [__] nothing
nobody's getting [__] nothing
your [__] sheriff neighbors is
pinching
[Music]
i wouldn't say a word i could record him
over the course of like four months and
go hey
i can do whatever i want right it's just
tickets i have
i never in my life like imagine a
scenario where like my neighbor is like
an older dude and he's talking to me
like bro but he's saying like what he's
trying to say is yo you guys are putting
pressure on me because you're [__]
doing so much to this house
pissed yeah like we we just put in the
new garage door that was a big [__]
thing why uh why'd you do it because we
had to
isn't that crazy you live in a
neighborhood like no fix it yeah when
you buy a house and a haunt you have a
homeowner's association they can tell
you yeah i mean granted the [__] door
was hanging off it's like we have a new
house
they they'll they'll walk by and be like
you have so much time to fix this so
you're gonna start getting fined isn't
that crazy it's my property oh i had a
moment with the with the dude at the uh
homeowners association
because i went i had ariana was doing
volleyball tryouts so i take cam ariana
and emmy to the
homeowners club
all right
there's i posted up on instagram there's
lake oh yeah yeah yeah there's boats
there's [__] gym all this [__] we
haven't used it yet
we've been there we've been there a year
almost so i'm like alright we'll go
practice some volleyball i take the kids
over there
swipe in and they try to charge me to
bring the kids in why
i'm like
because they want you to pay a
membership for each person in the house
and i'm like uh
no i got three kids here
i i didn't understand it was set up like
that and the dude was being a little
little
um not
customer
cam told me i was embarrassing him and
[__] and we just left
you're mad at the guy yeah because i'm
like
i didn't understand at first and then i
i'm like
telling them basically
you need to just let us come through
like you're
there it's about to be dark out like we
own this house we've never even used
this before pretend she's my wife i
don't
like and then he's like ralph's you
could actually go to ralph's and take
out money out of the atm they even have
an atm and and when he said that i was
like
it's
like this is really about this five
dollars you're not going to let my
[__] how old does she [__] 13 14
year old daughter come in it's really
about this five dollars for this half
hour of sunlight i mean like not even
that you own a house right we own
we pay monthly to the homeowners
association
i just painted my whole [__] house
it's like [__] thousands of dollars
because they told me to just replaced my
garage door more thousands because they
[__] told me to coming up season
three marty gets a new house
marty's
sold his moving
for profit and left that's tough boy
[__] that [__] tell me what i have to do
yeah in a little snobby little [__]
i'm a enemy like bro
if you're gonna put lay this [__]
policy down on me you don't gotta be all
[__] clerical about the [__] dude
look at me i'm sorry i know this is
seems petty that we're holding you up
for five cash and we don't even accept
debit or nothing but cash or like
that guy really doesn't charge he just
wants [__] money at the end of the
day that's what that's how i made it
yeah that's what it feels like before i
that's the little [__] i said to him
before i [__] spun off and left and
just took him to a different park so
marty's never going back there because
marty screamed at the man is what i'm
hearing
i've had a couple confrontations this
past month
all right but that's a classic move why
are you doing this
grabbing the mic
you know he's like
yeah i'm not gonna say it
yeah we got the gym going in the garage
though so it's alright i don't give a
[__]
i need to get out there and shoot some
baskets though i need a hobby besides
just taking pictures of league dunk
start dunking watch it's gonna reverse
marty's gonna start being the pictures
that we gotta be like no no my
kickboxing [__] i got taller
a bunch of stuff happened
what could happen you never know oh no
to sum this all up
august 25th be on the lookout all that
happened
i don't even remember this one let's let
this [__] run for massive action though
it's got the griselda feature
[Music]
all right all right since we're talking
about
hometown [__] let me say some [__] let
me uh tell a small little story for you
guys i have a video coming out on the
adventures of yolo channel very soon
about it
you ready i had my first meet and greet
my hometown meet and greet ever in
merced had a meet and greet
i'll be honest
i was a little nervous that not a lot of
people would show up i was hoping just
for his his store it's merced merced
small it's
it's on it's on martin luther king
that's where i'm from you remember not a
lot of people want to be over there
chris rock
that he was like
it's just funny that martin luther king
oh it's all the ghetto parts are all
about the kids he's like stood for
non-violence at peace anywhere in the
country yeah violence going down it's
true
it's true
tarnishing his [__] name anywhere in
any city you're yeah you're on the most
dangerous street in that city if you're
on here okay for a [__] shirt yeah
but my mom texts me all right i'll tell
you a little story real quick behind the
scenes because we'll get this on the
adventures channel she was security no
my mom hit me because i took my little
brother rocco and my little brother is
not sheltered but
he grew up not where i grew up you know
he grew up my mom he grew apart hawaii
came back lived in the [__] country
not in gangland yeah he's never grew up
in that i grew up in that my mom's over
there trying to like
hey you need to be cautious and i guess
she was like he's not taking me serious
[__] tell him
i tell him [__] but i'm like yeah are
you gonna come do my booth he's gonna
help me right
so i had my homie trent there to film it
me rosie my little brother rocco we're
gonna run the booth also do the meet and
greet
and my mom's like could you make sure
everything's okay i'm like mom
i if something's wrong i'm sending rocco
home immediately and i'm to stand there
by myself
oh [__] i would never risk my little
brother or rosie's right there like no
so i [__] try to hire because he has
a security guard i'm like all right to
make my mom feel better what if i hired
like two security guards you feel better
mom if i get two dudes of guns standing
at the door she's like yes
she didn't ask me to i was like i'll do
it just to chill
i don't know why is it because
we said where it was
[Music]
of course everything said sounded cool
at first and then we told him merced
this plan they go okay well hold on
six bands they wanted
for four dudes
four
four guys saves like a lot okay
i was just thinking how much it would be
a rack i'll spend a round about 1200
bucks yeah yeah yeah [__] it let's do it
my mom feel better i'll do it damn
and then the guy came back what about
two and we call another company goes uh
1400 each go oh [__]
disco what
like yeah you know same day
like dude these fools aren't working
today yeah they're available
yeah do they want to make some come
stand in front of the store with your
license gun yeah we got it was fine it
was totally cool we didn't need to
[__]
even need it but to make my mom feel
better anyway i haven't talked to you
about this at all really yeah i'll tell
the behind the scenes story here but the
ventures at viola channel on youtube is
going to get the whole vlog
all right so i get there i pull up
and
there's like three fans that come around
the store like a store next door buy
right by race now chevron which is crazy
and um
his store is right on martin luther king
across the street from where i used to
work u-haul i used to work at that
u-haul across the street
uh i grew up right down the [__]
block dude it's so [__] weird
and uh oh i'm coming into town
a rock this big just smacks my
windshield breaks my [__] brand new
rosie's car just bust the whole [__]
like oh man
of course i'm pulling up to the me and
you're like
[Music]
busted yesterday ghetto ass windshield
like dude you drive like that from l.a
damn tom's still ghetto it's fine with
no fool
yeah it just happened i mean an exit
before i got off dude i saw it come i'm
like oh look at that moth
like damn i was gonna hit the windshield
but it was a white rock just crack my
[__]
anyway continued [__] it was terrible
cocaine rocks flying at you yeah it was
a [__] crack rock
four tweakers
went on the street and got it right
after
a couple fans come out shout out to you
guys oh
first thing i noticed
push trees beanie push tree shirt push
trees
uh shorts this dude hat on it's like
[__] yeah
him and two of his homies shout out to i
think he had like an undertaker shirt on
and his other homie reminded me of my
friend the dude like my height with the
long curly hair he reminded me one of my
homies from high school this first thing
i thought was like wow you look just
like my [__] homie anyway they helped
me with all my [__] we picked up all
stuff and carried it in there was nobody
outside i'm like oh [__] i really hope
people show up
but i walk in and there's already hella
fools in there cuz it was hot
dude i got there 40 minutes early
and it started right then and there
i meet marty i got there
carrying the stuff in go back to moving
my car
and there was a [__] line wrapped
around the building these people must've
been just sitting in the car waiting
because it was hot
yeah bro there was a line busy uh is
that like uh
no it's unless you're twas
since you're a tweaker you'd not walk
around there gotcha
i looked like yo are you [__] kidding
me
i'm like it's like
all right cool so i go inside we set up
real quick cause there's so many people
i'm like oh i felt bad they're sitting
there while i'm setting up
and i got there 40 minutes early to make
sure i set up the booth i felt dumb i'm
like oh i'm so sorry you guys are
standing here while i'm putting stuff on
the table so stupid i felt so dumb
so sorry for that but also they got
there early
so i go outside i move the car i come
back and the [__] first person i
really talked to bro i walk up and it's
my one of my it's my best friend from
childhood [__] shout out to scotty
homie scott ducey bro i walk up i'm like
who is this foot
oh my god he was my best friend from
like sixth to ninth grade and he moved
damn yeah then he moved and we went to
different schools and the last time i
saw him i was changing a tire
when i was 18 i was late for school it
was finals i go out to my car for
college and my [__] tire's flat on
the ground like of course
of course it's like that [__]
so i get under there so i changed the
tire hella fast because i only have a
couple minutes to get to class
and some dudes oh hey i was like oh [__]
about to get robbed under my car damn
i'm vulnerable like what the [__]
and i look and it was [__] scotty and
i was like oh my god i was the last time
i saw him i was 18 years old
and i saw him at the meet and greet but
he was right there like oh my god it was
just
wild to me dude was it mostly people
from merced or people driving in from
all over i'll tell you right now that's
what shocked me i get inside we start
i mean bro there were so many [__]
people
and another thing shout out to everyone
that came and cannabis cups obviously
everyone's 21 and older [__] 50 years
old 40 years old 30 22 no matter
the first 500 people were all 18 and
under
like 16 to 18 year olds like they yo
i'll watch your [__] pocket first
thing where's marty first thing the
podcast was like
half the you fools are here because of
the show not even the weed video like
yeah i watch you read videos too but the
show the podcast like oh [__] yeah
right but all these i'm like yo our
demographic is
wild you're 16 to 18. all these two you
tell every one of these people were just
got like ditched school i had a couple
people like yo i said [__] that i'm not
going to school today like i'm not going
to miss this what the [__] [__] and i
never would have considered that and
like six of his home like yeah we all
did school bro
we're all here i'm like first off i feel
kind of i i didn't ask you to
didn't ask you to because it was a meet
and greet there was no weed smoking
we're not selling weed anyone could come
the first time i've ever done that ever
the first time i've ever done an
all-ages thing
and so many [__] people showed up
cannabis cups you you've seen two five
[__] line of [__] 70 people for
three four hours
taking pictures and [__] like that is
sick but they're all adults and i've
never seen the younger crowd and ever
just stopping at restaurants and they
saw take a pic that's different
but i'd never gone an event where the it
was a younger crowd at first like all
the first people were so young like whoa
good [__] like it was cool anyway i'm
talking to people
if three 400 people if like 300 people
say showed up right all together
seventy percent of them weren't even
from merced
they were all surrounding little cities
and i asked everybody where are you from
every [__] person where are you from
and i got all the little cities remember
said like all the little towns dude it
was cool as [__] i got some people
driving up from bakersfield chico chino
the bay salinas santa rosa
had like a group of like four like four
dudes come from santa rosa we all drove
we got off work and all just drove
we did not have a full line out the door
we had to like i felt back it was hot so
i was trying to like get people in
but there was a line non-stop for like
three and a half four hours dude
straight it was so [__] cool rosie's
whole family came in periodically like
her mom came her sister and brought
everybody and they brought the baby
because yo it was fine we're not smoking
a shoe store
excuse me it's just a shoe store
first off that shoe store [__]
awesome
the only one that's ever been in merced
and when i walked in you're like dude
there's a shoe i'm going like damn shut
a [__] tear for this i'm so happy for
you right now you have a shoe store
merced
i was so excited like dude are you
[__] kidding me
and like 20 people came in that weren't
even for the meet and greet they just
didn't buy shoes
this is so [__] cool
and i had a hell of people
there were so many people i signed so
much [__] and then you saw me sign
someone's car yeah shout out to you i i
signed your car all right i signed
someone's car your car is [__] famous
my handwriting is really bad i signed
the dash of this car and i asked him
three times are you
sure it wasn't an old car it was a nice
it was a nice truck i was wondering what
it was it was a nice truck like a toyota
i could like a tacoma or one of those
bigger trucks like dude there's a nice
truck and i asked him multiple times are
you sure
and then i went are you sure and i
recorded it
are you sure yeah were you inside and he
asked you like if you come outside
inside my [__] dashboard yeah yeah
so i ran outside really did it damn
and i don't know what's going on
instagram they just want me to not show
weed i showed you i posted that it's at
2 million views
on my instagram
i only got 50 000 on this new page i
just got deleted again so i only have
like two million views it's on some
non-weed [__]
just me and everything you write like a
child like damn that's the one that
blows up my horrible signature that's
the one that does good on instagram [__]
the least ever
but i was trying to write nice and i
want to say
that was my best signature
i'm bad at this
i said so much [__] dude i must have
signed like 500 different [__] things
we sold out of the push tree [__] that
we brought i only brought stuff to bring
it
it's [__] people buy right here i
couldn't believe it what kind of
sneakers they have up in there hell of
[__]
hell [__] so much just
it's like going to riff l.a but small at
merced you know riff's a big store it's
like the
shoes the big shoe store here that like
has the [__]
rare the
jordan is jordan all that stuff
but um
i just want to say thank you guys so
much i did not think that many [__]
people would come
i was so stoked at first just the first
line i'm like oh oh people showed up
thank you
and i saw the person i saw on the end
line inside i'm like and i took a look
what the [__] i looked outside it was
wrapped again
it never stopped not one [__] time
it was must have been so [__] hot it
was so hot and that's why i kept saying
thank you for coming here i know it was
so [__] hot do you feel like pressure
the whole time like
to get through like you want to spend
time and talk to each person
i talked to everybody until they were
done talking hmm
you just let it run its course
oh yep
that's how you got to do it i suppose i
just couldn't be like you take a picture
with everybody every single [__]
person
that's that's amazing yeah that
meeting all the fans of secret session i
don't think we talked about on here for
me like changed everything they've just
made it way more like
they'd be more fired up now in person
yeah you think people are just saying
that to be nice and then you meet him in
person you said the same [__] that i've
been reading for a year
yeah and it was funny because like
uh who was it
nikita was like
because i was this was the first time i
was just standing there talking to the
fans signing [__] taking pictures
meeting fans like face to face and
nikita was like what's it feel like to
be a celebrity and i was like i don't
know
and i'm like i want i want fans
signatures when they come up like i want
to be like
give it away i'm not going to give it
away but i'm just saying like i wanted
to be like a lifetime the other day i
want to shake you guys like no thank you
like thank you for making this possible
i appreciate you guys being so nice like
i want to take a moment thank you
yeah that's how it is bro that's why you
see me talk to people for [__] 20
minutes and like bro we're just talking
they're going over so they made this
video like nah bro this is what happened
let me tell you what really happened so
i was [__] up and i did this and
what is the opportunity going to come
again
we might not ever meet that person again
you know what i mean and i want them to
always go home thinking like no i met
that dude one time i follow
exactly like i've hoped and that's what
i want to hear forever like
why wouldn't it be like i want you
everyone to ever [__] interact with
us but yeah i mean marty's [__]
awesome
because why wouldn't it be
because you know when you meet somebody
you you watch you go were they cool the
first thing you ask right yo i bet
[__] random saddler this week was he
tight
it's the first thing everyone asks when
you meet somebody that people like are
they cool
yes that's super [__] cool that's all
he cares about
all that matters like just make that
person happy
because not everybody gets the
opportunity to just exist and make
someone happy
do stuff you like and people love it oh
[__] holy [__] you won
yeah yeah and it's and it's
free which is it's free to be nice yeah
well i'm saying like and this whole
situation was free to people right
oh yeah oh the meet and greet yeah of
course i [__] up
i should have gave all the clothes away
instead of sold them but i sold them at
cost damn near but i'm saying most
people charge like you might have to
yeah but i just felt weird like at the
end i'm like
i should have brought double the amount
and if you bought something or showed up
giving you something
[__] it i'll just tell my [__]
accountant be like yo i gave away the
[__] five thousand dollars [__]
[__]
but
can i write that some of that up yeah
and that would help and if i can't [__]
it it was merced
i [__] up i felt like i should have
brought a lot more stuff i didn't think
that many people would come dude that's
really what happened i did not think
that many people wonder how many people
that was i don't know dude would you say
it was probably the most people you've
had show up where you're like taking
pictures and [__] no like the cannabis
cups and like there's like thousand
people yeah more throughout the day day
or two oh yeah because they're there for
an event yeah they're it's a centralized
place this was a open city if you want
and you saw the flyer come
but cannabis comes like everyone's there
and they happen to see you or everyone's
there know that you're gonna be there or
they go because they know you have a
booth
that's like
different that's e that's like the easy
way of like oh all our fans could be
here at once
showing up to a meet and greet in the
heat
one of the first people in line is like
his mom would talk to me like 10 minutes
about like yo my [__] son's a huge
[__] family
just break because he couldn't drive
he's too young like i was hyped as [__]
and she was telling me like no we
legitimately watch your [__] like a joke
all of us we watch it [__] at night
oh my god i never think about that all
the time that's how people watch it man
people tell me all the time like no my
whole family watches one of the best
feelings ever was like the kid that came
up with his dad and his dad oh with the
[__] uh are you talking about the
magazine yeah you got blood tender of
the month
yeah out of vegas out of planet 13. okay
i can't remember his first name so i
don't even want to say it red hair right
yeah and his dad met his dad last time
no i'd secret says [__] you the dad was
like
good motivation for my boy all that type
of [__] i'm like good [__] didn't think
i was gonna be having dads come up to me
like nice oh yeah yeah you wouldn't be
shocked on the older crowd that we got
do you have at the cannabis because i
have like a 60 year old man like a
seven-year-old man like she had a tear
you're so happy like you are
you were in a war
you're allowed to be in war yeah you're
just tearing up so happy right now this
is amazing dude the older crowd that i
meet is great because
when i you know say we see a 15 year old
dude half our age
doing something sick we're [__]
hyping go good [__] [__] and
that's what the older crowd's looking at
it's like good [__] man you guys do what
you want [__] yeah
that's how i see people yeah very true i
think it's
it's just you're not a [__] hater i
think it's what it boils down to like
are you a [__] hater and you probably
won't say nothing
because look
to be positive and just say some [__] to
somebody like you walk
say you're at the cannabis cup and you
watch his fool's videos and you're just
too [__] cool like oh good [__] bro
you know how many people i mean like
that bro and then like 10 minutes later
when they're homies aren't they it was
so full like mainly hard ass fools but
it's like hey you could it's okay to
smile yeah it's okay to laugh
[__] you're seeing gangster
movies they crack jokes
you can be funny you're allowed to be
funny don't worry because i got a lot of
uh
i got a lot of fans from the valley that
are
not gang bangers but you know affiliated
ass fools also gangbangers
and uh
they'll be like hey what's so full man
good [__] and then looking no one's
around like yeah watch your [__] like
i'll just
just open up man
i wish people wouldn't like i get it
though that's where you're from who
you're with i get it but it's not cool
to like let's it's not cool don't you
love this show yeah i was like oh i wish
you could
makes me like [__] that's sad i'm
happy all the time cause you're like you
kind of geek out on the community
together that's what you're really doing
yeah yeah it's true like i think it's
great when i see somebody that i've like
even his other weed [__] like yo [__]
yeah because it's cool i like that [__]
uh just don't be a hater um i have no
idea we went with this oh meet and greet
thanks thanks for coming
like last week i had a random ass i
always have this weird ass [__] panic
dream that like yo all that music you're
working on
for
you got to perform it in front of a
crowd right now you don't even remember
the [__] and you don't know the word
like
[Laughter]
[__] yeah and i always go on stage and i
wake up like oh and it always makes me
think you're not prepared what are you
doing and not just i'm not saying i'm
just an example but that's uh
i don't know where i went with that i
can't remember what we were talking
about wow
yeah but having that fanny dream oh yeah
and the dream and i went out this time
usually it's in front of a crowd and i
went
there's eight people here this is way
easier and i was like is this what the
meet and greet's going to be like i hope
not i hope not for the shoe store's sake
they do all this [__] nobody comes but
no bro hell look i mean it was
successful so that's the dream i have a
scary thing like you know the pressure's
on me man i don't want you guys to put
in all this effort and
drive all the way up it's not for my ego
it's for you you guys got people you're
working you brought food like
what if you had extra food at the end
like that's terrible yeah
yeah
that's what i mean so i was happy it
worked thanks shout out to gb i'm glad
that [__] went yeah dude shout out to
him for real man like and i will say
this right now
i went to go say bye to him because
they're in the back they had the boost i
didn't get to outside any of the boots
in the back they had boost all in the
back of the meet and greet
like where people could chill they had
food and this and that i didn't go back
there once because i couldn't leave yeah
i went back there
and i'm like that's why i [__] with this
fool i saw gb he was just sitting there
in all his outfit shout out to you for
wearing push trees too that was hard as
hell i see him rolling up the bounce
house sweating his ass off him and his
homie you're picking it up so we got all
these chains and i'm like i [__] with
both of you guys
good [__]
like
good because most [__] by
touching this [__] like for i pay this
[__] to do that
yeah and then i helped him [__] lift
it and then when i got in the car i
realized like
oh i just stained my [__] shorts oh
but it doesn't matter i just like dude
what a i love that that's why i'm here
this motherfucker's putting his own [__]
away it is hot as [__]
oh yeah i was i felt good it felt right
that felt just like your hometown doing
that this
was the right thing to do yeah it drove
as i drove off
we ran into uh rosie's dad's real good
friend shout out to lance
and he stopped we stopped
and he didn't know about the meet and
greet or nothing he blocked from his
house oh and i was leaving this big
[__] gangster dude was like oh you're
done like i'm sorry it's over
it's like it's all i was watching video
about it like yeah
this is a grown [__] man like good
[__] i just loved it and people were
like
and not just like what's so full yeah
god thank you like break that [__]
anyway see lance like i was wondering
who the [__] was driving this car on
11th street and i saw your face and i
was like oh
oh yeah huh i forgot about that
right where i was right now like oh [__]
because i brought the new car with a
[__] bus
um but anyway i drove by my [__] old
school it was just weird dude i drove
blocks away i'm like i just didn't meet
and greet
here's my old school where i was like
i [__] because my whole life was like
what am i gonna do i'm gonna do
something [__] sick i always just
think that i'm gonna do something badass
and everybody's gonna love that [__] i
should just say it
so [__] stoked when i went back to
school i was like wow
i used to get bullied here all the time
[__] yeah
you guys get [__] picked on [__] you
guys
[__] you kids go here
yeah i mean that's just i don't know it
was a story it was fun man good day what
a beautiful [__] story it was a good
day all through the [__] flower here
oh wait we got two fat joints what time
are we at i'm gonna say
129.
130. oh
[Music]
that was a good one you ready to smoke
this cherry blotto
[__] yeah oh ho once again chavo
thank you
you know how happy marty is right now
marty's from the buffalo the buffalo
dirt i feel like i've made it now
finally got the wheels logo on the
[__] yeah i know let's go all right
unofficial youtube sorry yeah we're not
getting paid or anything we're just
smoking weeds our homie it's good
looking we're just saying thanks for
[__] supplying us with the weed
thank you sir that's the sheriff [__]
i'm excited it's like the olympic torch
and [__] yeah
because marty always rolls joints during
because i'm always rolling joints going
hold on let's start sorry i'm almost
done i'm almost done because
and i'm like dude do you want real joint
steering and i'm like oh i'm just
running
for you it's distracting because i'm
always getting this camera set up and
[__] and then i'll always just roll a
joint what episode did we have did we
finally figure it out
no don't say a hundred no it's not yeah
i'm not i'm not close to a pull-up
oh [__] i forgot about that yeah we're
closing in four months ago hold on this
is up what's 45 plus 35.
okay 80. yeah let's say we have four
months
huh
you've been working out
you got to start tournaments pull ups
all right
what was the hold on what was the like
if you lose don't win the bet what was
that
i didn't bet [__]
i'm saying i would love to do that and
when i hold myself accountable to things
i do it
so
i hope i do it yo my hair's on [__]
uh
uh guy that stomps the mouse in the
green mile right now
percy
my hair's on [__] percy right now i i
know exactly what you're talking about
because you said that in a yola video
and i overlaid him did did i mm-hmm
well that's what i feel like right now
my hair is gross
um
can we just talk about the fact that
we've been going so ham we're really i
feel like even though we've been doing
this the whole time we're getting now
into a groove with the posting and the
level oh we just started getting locked
down which is crazy
but dude you don't have time
it's lit people don't know
ready film on monday say we film on
monday
i export that foot issue which takes
overnight now we're just
ubering drives
that [__] worked great right you got in
an hour man this pool pulled out to my
house you came out with a [__] paper
bag he didn't know what was going on he
thought it was a drug deal yeah he
really he did because it was so light
like he thinks this is a pack
so i put fragile stickers on it it
couldn't look sketchy i know but i told
him like yo this right here is a hard
drive for my editor and i told him
everything because i know he thought it
sounds are you having me drop off a
brick in orange county
you're paying how much to drop off one
single item
[Music]
that's what he thought weightless and i
said please give it to yeah it's
weightless you could throw it and it
would fly
i wrapped a single sd 250
gig sd card and this much bubble wrap
bubble wrap i put it in like one of
those like
big-ass brown paper bags and then i
stapled it shut and put fragile stickers
on yeah
television right brick on my brush
that's exactly what that [__] on there
he looked at me with
where's this going i go to my editor
this is the hard drive sd please be very
careful with it but do not leave it at
the door it has to go to him and i went
in my head oh i didn't know but
if he looked at me i'm like oh i'm
trying to make it sound more efficient i
was i was trying to make it sound more
official you know about a warehouse oh
it probably doesn't help either you got
the [__] push straight hair she's all
[__] hey
yeah the no bad vibe shirt on it [__]
i don't remember what i had on but i
remember
looking at him thinking [__] i hope he
gives that drive to marty he doesn't
just take off that gets a pack it's
possible you know like that's what i was
worried about
oh but oh we've said we film on monday
give him the drive
we film episodes on tuesday so you're
not gonna start editing that [__] until
tonight that that tuesday night
all day tuesday on a tuesday night all
day wednesday
thursday takes three days to get us a
video
right but if we're posting two times a
week on my channels
that's six days plus the edit of the
podcast that's nine days a week there's
not nine days in the week if you haven't
got up yet yeah where's the adventure
channel
so so
so
what we're kind of seeing right now what
we're merging into is
we're getting ready to hand the podcast
over here pretty soon
and
even we're kind of zippering into that
right now
but and as of when this podcast goes out
it's probably going to be no longer
available
but i made it available to the drastic
graphics instagram community
part-time remote video editor position
has been going down this whole week so
i've gotten about a hundred applications
we finally hiring yeah i'm gonna bring
on i'm gonna bring out a video editor to
help me because even even after handing
over the podcast edit
still gonna be i'm still gonna need
at least one editor to help manage
everything
but i mean it's gonna be beautiful i
can't wait because like we're just gonna
we're gonna be [__] we already are
cranking out so much content across
these different channels and to be able
to just kind of really sit and focus and
just do my thing with it
uh we're growing the dopest channels too
which is crazy that's its own there's so
much well the dopest goes on my channel
we're just like every tuesday we're
trying to drop a video for the dopest so
me and john one of the owners of the uh
of hash the owner of hash house one of
the owners of the dopest
we're good friends we've been having for
a long time he's a goofy [__] so we've
been doing videos together that's fun
every friday me and him record now it's
crazy i added another filming date in my
schedule
but it's so fun dude like the more
content the better i'm [__] with it
let's run it like
we just need help you cannot do it on
your own try not to get married to work
on the weekends it's impossible
yeah a five-day work week when there's
nine days of work
but [__] hire somebody that's where
we're at so yeah marty finally got yeah
some people but it's also like you you
never want to stop leveling up like i
can teach a class on how to edit the
podcast that's
i wanna i'm gonna grow beyond that you
know and just
keep pushing because i'm just excited
that's really one of the big chapters
that we're coming to like we got the
house
now we're like getting back
now i'm gonna get my time back get
on a more routine schedule just in life
like i it's just [__] is continuing to
level up oh yeah it is
yo i know that whoa
you got it so delicious that time no
this is the we both smoking the sheriff
right now okay cool this tastes like
real dill sherb from my 2015.
you got that taste i don't know about
that
shibinsky mario shout out to him for
[__] breeding that [__] sure sure uh
sherbert sunset sherbet rainbow sherbet
oh that's okay
the breeder you had him in a video early
on right
he's mad cool he's a big fat dude
it's a bit it's a quick story
what i used to run all the cookie [__] i
used to run all their social medias
right
uh like 2014 2015.
and this is before they were connected
cookies and connected we're the same
company they broke off i know the owners
of connected
they used to own cookies and then
obviously they had burner was the other
owner or however that worked out or what
percentage is i don't know but i know my
home is luke you know what i mean
and his brother
they own connected but they used to be
cookies that's why they [__] see and
they
that's why the logos look so similar i
don't know what the situation was but
they don't work together anymore i don't
know what i don't know
but uh
what's it saying oh you used to run all
this [__] right
so she wrote her social media so i'm in
there one day
and i think it's harry gordy a couple
other people and this big
[__] mexican dude walks in
i mean like a big dude look like batista
the the wrestler
and uh
i'm standing there with luke he's like
yo i'm gonna change some money [__] do
you mind stepping out real quick of
course i'm gonna step the [__] out but
he was like he's just being polite like
yo i don't want to pay all these fools
their money and give them their money
because they're doing stuff in front of
somebody they've never met so i felt
like yeah of course i'll step out
i was about to step out that big mexican
dude turns around
he looks at
me he looks at me like
not like i [__] up but more like
shocked
he looked at me and i go oh [__] what
the [__] and he just
jumps in the [__] air
get the [__] out of here
and he goes go piss y'all he starts
yelling my name like
oh [__] yeah man what's up dude i'm like
oh you're huge
you're scary as [__] you're a big ass
fan
and he's like yo big fan bro nice to
meet you nice mario
i'm like cool man nice to meet you nice
to meet you
and he shakes my hand and he looks over
show like that and he brings me and he
goes i'm scherbinski
and i go what the [__] i have been
talking to him before there was dms
on instagram for three [__] years
like we were friends online before i
ever i knew him didn't know that was him
you know post his face now he's all over
his [__] because he's legal so he's good
but he's like i'm shibanski and that's
how we
and i looked at him like what some
heisenberg shirt
no way because me and him talk online
all the time we just never met so i'm
like as he's like going crazy i'm like
oh it's a fan
but i didn't know that oh my friend that
we never met i didn't know him i've
never seen a picture of him before
it was [__] awesome but shout out to
shibinsky he's the one that put on the
sherb heavy and then something else i
saw the other day that i realized
okay story time orange is my [__] i love
it i've been using forever
we go hard with the orange packaging
because i love it yeah
i just realized that's the same [__]
strabinski orange he uses
i feel so dumb i felt like i kind of bit
it but i didn't of course it didn't
story time orange is our [__] that's our
color yeah but i just saw the vape i go
why have i seen that oh
my god i felt so like
i promise i didn't do it on a [__]
purpose bro that's how i felt like i
swear to god i like you i did not do it
on purpose to [__] with you i just it's
story time oranges are [__] yeah but
when i saw the vape went
that's where i've seen it
is this [__] is is scherbinski still out
there heavy like he's at a store on
[__] fairfax oh no [__] yeah shout
out to shibinsi yeah he's cool he's a
cool [__] oh yeah i like him
so this is like their take on that
strain because so oh no sure blotto
bottle is gelato mixed with sherbet
i'm just saying the sherbs this tastes
like because he gave me a batch of his
personal weed a long time ago
and it was just like a goal it was gold
the grower handing you his personal
[__] stash of his own strain that he
oh
i savored that [__] for a month
but uh this tastes like it like a lot
like it so i'm very very stoked what a
story
what a [__] long-ass story out of
nowhere what the [__] happened i'm sorry
i just realized it was all from that
uh-huh
let's just hit that like a pookie oh my
god i'm so sorry
i'm my father's child
i'm gonna start i'm gonna i'm gonna get
we're gonna get age restricted i'm not
going to say it
oh i wanted to say it
so fun it would have been so fun dude
leave it in the comments
say me and marty hit you guys up and was
like yo we're not going gonna post on
youtube anymore
we're only going to spotify
would you guys be mad hold on yeah but
would you guys be happy if you like but
marty and thomas are now millionaires
wouldn't you be happy for us
and now they can just not have to ever
worry i ever have to censor ourselves
again and bring on [__]
packs just lay packs right here like
today we're gonna be smoking out this
pound shout out to so-and-so
i [__] wish man
that is when we really excel um
do what we want because the [__] i was
about to say i know in my head kind of
classic yeah classic to me
certain people might think i'm a piece
of [__] for saying it but i think it's
funny and if you don't then you don't
have to watch it our conversations are
scaled back by at least 30 percent oh it
gets rough when me and this [__]
on facetime we're saying stupid [__]
sometimes you go marty could you imagine
if we talk about this or how many times
you say that could you imagine how quick
the show would be gone if we said that
some of the [__]
some of the [__] we say
yeah and there is no deal with spotify
like this yet
we would just love that yeah it will be
yeah that's goals
no speaking into existence yeah yeah
give us both 10 million dollars
we will make that move
a year though yeah
not for the whole show the real point is
no it would be nice to just be able to
live yeah yeah i would love it like what
they said oh you guys aren't doing porno
you're not doing hate speech why would
we mess with you thank you that's what
he said to us yeah you're not like
saying racist [__] are you i'm like no
like why would they age restrict it
that's what spotify said i don't [__]
know
you tell me in the same conversation
they said let's monetize your channel
too while we're at it thank you [__]
spanish yeah so shout out to spotify for
[__] monetizing us thank you spotify
on spotify
[Music]
yo
shout out to the spotify
[__]
un un asked verified marty yeah [__]
with us
called us
they respond right away they do
everything they say they're gonna do
they instantly gave a story time channel
to me yeah that we're about to start
[__] with oh yeah by the way by the
way story time is going to be on spotify
as a [__] channel should have said
that
i'm about to have that [__] down to
where you don't even hear his voice
anymore and i just go over it so
perfectly
it was almost there i just needed the
last
i just needed to hear it again yeah so
thank you that's encouraging i love that
and it's like
we're a youtube community here but we
fight against the grain in every episode
that [__] broke my heart that you got
just missed episode i know we called it
age restricted but still that was it was
supposed to be ironic and it wasn't even
that bad
jessamy paluso episode last week is age
restricted
we even do anything we'd even monetize
it
what more do you want not just not to
post this [__]
that's the live [__] step man
oh we're getting upset now
because yeah apparently a lot of our
fans are in that under 18
demo yeah we're just talking come on
selling [__]
some therapy sessions better help yeah
the [__] else you need better help
what did we do we took an ad for some
help with to help people
we're not taking nicotine ads
the [__]
don't mind the hash press ad you might
be getting anyway from the ad sensor
yeah this [__] whole thing just
turned into a [__] just
and another thing it turned into
festivus
airing of grievances i didn't get really
frustrated until i saw literally a
[__] rosin press being advertised on
the episode
on our channel raw's impress oil coming
out
but we can't get eight what what we
can't
host we're age restricted
all she did was
say some stuff she even said nothing
crazy
the last episode i understand
yes i understand her first episode yeah
kids probably shouldn't watch it yeah
but what are you gonna do what exactly
but what are you gonna do that's my
whole thing of life what are you gonna
do it's like ricky williams said though
you wanna just
you wanna look around and see who's for
you you mean so we just wanna just
[__] thank spotify because yeah it's
just it doesn't feel good to go against
the grain we love you you two are your
effort but ricky williams taught us
who's the benefit for us holding me back
from not being able to say [__] within
the first eight seconds or [__]
it's not good for my health that's like
holding it in your pee you ever seen
liar liar
i heard it's about really bad for your
bladder is that true i should probably
take a break then
come on man
come on come on man this is our asmr
right here come on man help us out come
on youtube oh you gotta scare the [__]
out of me for a second it sounded like a
[__] walking through the woods
yeah dead
wow
i thought of brown leaves in a boot i
would have said more right now
in trouble
oh oh everybody driving up here sorry
all right
so
i wanted to update everybody
we updated we moved
all right the door guy called me sir
and they gave me a champagne bottle when
they got in that's my keys and i went yo
i'm adult i'm an adult officially
holy [__]
i mean that's some l.a shirt it was
crazy as hell
when i got in there are you f as me and
rosie sat down we looked at you like
remember the last episode of fresh
prince
it was empty empty that's how i felt
oh that's where we're gonna live all our
shits and boxes but
[__]
and then we
real quick let's sum it up i love this
i don't care how much money we ever make
in our lives i will never turn into a
bougie [__]
you know what the [__] happened today
last night first night in the [__]
penthouse the new spot love it it's so
[__] amazing
ac doesn't work in our room
brand new building first people to ever
move in
i mean it's an ice box in the living
room holy [__] you can't sit under it or
you're [__] it's that cool it's like
this
it's bad but good yeah that's ideal yes
get in the room like
like i'm feeding i'm [__] sweating
what the [__] and i go under the thing
it's not pumping at all but it's [__]
70 degree i'm like no
so that was like four in the morning i
woke up like ah covered in sweat i call
him this morning let him know this is
where i say that that's why i brought it
up i don't care what we do
or how tall we get i'll never be a
bougie [__] like this
i tell me the ac is out and he goes ah
they're not going to come till tomorrow
[__] bro all right
so what we can do is bring you a
portable air conditioner the full
[__] opened out the plastic
grabbed it a sick ass air conditioner
but
but it's like a high rise so the windows
don't open like that
only a little baby one does
and the thing's not going to fit it
perfect of course not they're not going
to make the tube that goes to the ac to
fit our building
so he's like oh the rest of it's open
i'm like oh he goes don't worry i'll be
back this [__] wouldn't cut
cardboard out
transfer put yeah put cardboard up in my
[__] window
and put the air conditioner thing
hold on sorry before that that was this
morning last night as i stand on my bed
i realized that my bed frame is broken
in the middle
i told rosie like a week ago why am i
sinking man i'm [__] heavy why am i
so i told him like am i getting fatter
what the [__] my leg hurts i'm laying
this way am i that big that we're
sinking like in your mushroom trip yes
yes yes yes exactly like that but like
this just like slightly off enough to be
annoyed yeah
so that was just my leg is that that
flatters faster i just [__] going to
the chiropractor for like oh it's just
my leg
so we look under like oh it's broken
so last night i took the bed frame out
first night and put the bed right on the
[__] floor i like it on the floor
just like me and rosie when we first
started dating
it was so hot that we took our bed out
of the [__] room and put in the
living room ac we only had swamp cooler
put the bed in the middle of the living
room
and put the swamp cooler right in front
of us and slept and i looked at her and
i'm like
this is just like we first started
dating rosie lately no matter how much
we move or how much [__] we do
we can't get away from little things
that revert us back to this cardboard in
my window it's kind of rigged up on the
window rigged up on the window with tape
and my bed's on the ground like i'm back
to being 19 again this is crazy that
sounds funny i looked her and she was
like this is awesome like it is awesome
isn't it it's kind of awesome to think
back about it like
all right not tomorrow though [__] this
[__] like i paid too much for this
[__]
but tonight it's great like this is
nostalgic
did she say like you want to move the
[__] bed in the room in the living
room and go no and then then we went in
the room it was broke and go
[__] we might have to
it was so hot last night i never had ac
growing up people might not sound like
you need it
it's bad we haven't had ac in the whole
house past [__] five days oh yeah
this was ac broke dude what's going on
what's up with this i don't know what
the [__] is going on with us man but
they came to fix the [__] yesterday and
they're like all right we got it all
checked out that [__] was not fixed this
is still not [__] functioning this
one too they said they fixed it and now
it's worse
there's some conspiracy going on there's
something going on this damn freon
yeah yeah so i don't know but we've been
[__] sweating balls out the house
everybody's just glistening and that's
his hair she's so wet it's so [__]
hot she looks like a 1700s child
[Laughter]
she got polio from the 50s she was like
she was like one of those babies in the
picture of the photographer with the
ladies hold on her portion just like
this woman's about to sell one of her
children from the famine and all the
little kids yeah that's probably what me
look like exactly
you just give her like an old shirt and
she looks like what century are you from
little girl
transcends they're timeless yeah a
little little little white girl with
brown hair like you look like
it's 1400s or it's 2012.
she's funny bro i heard her as she was
getting off the floor
we were talking this morning
it's when i facetimed you i heard i
heard it dad dad dad and it wasn't
little kid dad it was like wait what the
[__] happened because she's been going
to new york and i haven't talked i
haven't heard of the phone
she was saying dad not like a toddler
she was saying like a [__] little kid
and you kissed me i was like damn that's
it
well emery's gone now she's a [__]
kid not yeah she like runs [__] now i
know
there was a time where she wouldn't shut
up about
hi thomas oh that too hi
sneak in
and different no matter what
me and you'd be mid conversation and
that's it yeah she's over she runs [__]
she
it's weird having to be like oh this is
because we've decided like this is the
last baby
yeah yeah so it's like it's weird going
through the yeah
for the last time
keeping the dick
i thought you didn't hear me you were
just going to keep talking
i mean april decided to chop my dick off
we don't want kids anymore
and i just need to be more productive
she makes a strong argument you know
what i've been through three kids you
can't get a vasectomy you're not gonna
get one
it's reversible yeah i mean i should if
i kill one i'm not going back to get the
[__]
get it reversed like you
then you're then do it it doesn't hurt
you some people do it awake [__]
that's insane those fools are stupid put
me to sleep yeah no i wouldn't but it's
literally a couple of decisions yeah oh
it is isn't that crazy
i do know somebody that has one that had
a baby anyway so
maybe april should go get this person
you're sure it was his
for sure yeah it was a whole thing damn
yeah i don't know man i've been
i've been considering that [__] but
we'll see i don't know i think that
means no that means he's trying to say
it on here for the four percent of the
audience of women like i'm scared to get
my [__] lasik done i don't [__]
cut my balls off i don't think so
people talk about it like it's so simple
oh it's in it say
what they really do
yeah
they get a nail
[__] smacking the [__] out of you and
until you give up
that's that's what i picture basically
yeah yeah
i don't know exactly what they do
i don't even know what they do i know
what they do but think about it there's
no nice way around
what they got to do to do what they got
to do to [__] get in your balls like
it's not fun there's not there's no way
it's not it's not what they gotta do
they gotta do what they have to do to
get in your balls
stop
what the [__] is
you know like i've witnessed childbirth
that's horrific like
i'm like listen you've already endured
this horror like do it again
one little light version it's the light
app free app version april
show april this it's the free app
version
okay marty has to download new [__]
he might not get his money back it's
right it might not even work
i'm trying to muster up the [__]
courage to get a colonoscopy it's the
expansion pack april yeah what you
already went through it's okay
your grandfather didn't do another
[__] procedure your grandfather
didn't he'll pay
how about this like yo what i'll pay for
it you do it
give her that money before i swear to
god
the man the lord is [__] up man the
lord
what the [__] is happening where you
wired the [__] the lord's [__] up
the thing you brought him up
it's crazy to me this is what i was
thinking
come on you know you're the lord
it's [__] up
yo
speaking of that
my homie one shout out to one just moved
back okay have you remember when we won
the
fool that used to make medicated hot
wings and medicated lemonade
no you never met my homie one with the
long-ass dreads
oh he moved we've been chilling for
almost three years
he moved three years ago okay
he just moved back this week my homie
used to make medicated wings medicated
uh
hot wings you can't even say the name of
the company
because derogatory is [__] and
i can't
i'm trying to think of what it could be
for a wings coming i told him you have
to change the [__] name
because the second this old white
woman's like these wings are amazing
what is this dng stand for oh
what am i eating is this racist that i'm
eating the chicken it's called that
the mom is crazy he called it some crazy
name it's been that name for eight years
okay
never [__] sales up it's [__]
awesome i'm just saying like what if you
get big
target or something come on
anyway he's changing the name
he moved back but one of his child one
of his child's
his name's lord his first name okay and
you said
the lord's crazy that's the first thing
and i was like
well let me name his child lord
i won't give all the names out and we'll
say his last name
i don't know i think it's okay i don't
think he's gonna mind if i say the name
because he has 10 children oh 10. all
homeschooled
by his wife
all playing instrument and or sport
love it
all baller ass baller skaters every
[__] one of them and they'll have
dreads to their ankles
all of them
all homeschooled his wife says southern
like oh hello lady
white people with trump no he's black
okay all from atlanta
and they moved they lived here
he needs a [__] show
could you imagine damn he's one of the
best some of the best cookies i ever had
in my life was from one that's how i met
him
i met him at that like medicated
cookies uh girl scout cookie weed some
of the best road growed growing great
remember that place where you move the
bong and the door opens the fake
speakeasy i went to or the fake shop
yeah that's where i met him he was back
there doing the wings like the guy doing
the wings for everyone and i met him
we'd be friends for like [__] nine
years he's just he's awesome one like
o-n-e already okay
yeah um anyway it's my homie he needs
his own show
his dad
like has another family
and all his kids talk like cam
all
dreads they all sound like white kids
right all like you know
but they're all i mean nothing crazy
just like hmm
odd oh he got long dreads all you sound
like my friend's white children
his dad
this is why he needs a show his dad
remarried
lives in the south
has six children stepchildren all white
all i'm not not my words i'm not gonna
even say because we'll get in trouble
but he goes
i met all my siblings i go you got
siblings not my dad remarried
he's got like from 18 down they are six
i have six white brothers and sisters
like oh really goes
they met my kids
i don't know what happened but they all
talk like black southern kids and my
kids all sound like they're from the
beach
and they all meet and it doesn't work i
don't understand it's like i'm looking
at it going these white children are
talking like my grandma
he's like they're southern hick so he's
like they got that like southern twangs
like they all talk like they're in an
old 1800s movie all white kids blue eyes
and then all my kids with long dreads
all talk like they're from the beach san
diego what's up bro
and they all got dreads and skate and
play guitar
and it's like you won why don't you have
a show so for anybody out there with
power to get a tv show
run it um
you're welcome he has 10 children
they're all homeschooled they all have
this long ass baller ass hair
i'm trying to think of a creative ass
title this whole time dude just vlog it
hmm
he's got 10 kids first off first of all
she's just crazy plenty of people have
had shows just off that yes all
homeschooled
all do something cool they all have to
play a sport or instrument i mean my
homie needs a show he just moved back
like i can't imagine trying to
continue but when he told me he's like
oh my white brothers and sisters sound
like they're from
1840.
i can't believe that they're white so
they don't sound like children they
sound like grown men talking from 1891
like yo shut the [__] up he sent me a
picture it's a bunch of kids like
chilling outside like these are your
little brothers and sisters what you're
a grown man
but it's crazy because they chill with
his kids because all his kids are the
same [__] age because his dad
remarried later in life obviously i just
thought it was funny like yo what a wild
show scenario yeah you're right
i'm sold i'm sold i'm [__] sold just
to hear these kids accidents i want to
go like with the contrast and he's
making weed wings and [__] he stopped
doing that he's trying to be like he's
trying to do like his old thing but he
was in oklahoma do illegal weed stuff
for years
so it's just like an odd show
one of his his oldest son's twenty so
it's like
that
there's a show here
anyway i don't know how oh you said lord
yeah
so you know what if he's gonna be on the
tv anyway he needs to be on tv my friend
all right i'm just gonna tell you a few
i'll just tell you one name and then you
just take it from there
my homie and i asked what is your
children's name after i finally had 10
kids and he told me you're not [__]
serious
you're not you're lying to me
he's not lying and i asked him at the
end are you a religious person
no not really
my homie talks like he sounds like will
smith if you don't look at him he sounds
like [__] will it's the funniest i
always call most but it's [__] great
he named one of his children
first name god
[Music]
i like that take marty
i was i was wondering if that's what it
was going to be
first name g-o-d
first off you can never talk [__] to
that kid blasphemous can never fight him
you can't ever fight him don't ever
break up with him
i
all those things are bad all those sound
bad like
i dated god and i broke i cheated on him
like
[__]
but is that what jesus technically like
not god that's jesus all right middle
name power
um
that sounds like i got buffer saying
that name
imagine that running a football field
god power imagine that running another
[__] football field like
god power we're in for six like
go to a christian school and you're the
[__] sham bro everybody's gonna love
your ass you get jerseys you will have
jerseys made of you damn
i will say the rest of them but they're
wild that is not that's that's the top
that's like the top of the wild chain
one syllable what's the
most name i can give this kid in one
syllable
god
i'm with
controversy is built up in my chest
i can hear all the christians going why
you know like yeah it's not your
children i didn't even think about that
side of it i just thought about like
girl bringing home as a date what is
your boyfriend's name
god
um
my boy and buffalo got right across his
chest god's favorite
clean across
no
why dude
that's the opposite of being humble
you know what all dying kids
i'm the favorite you're i'm the favorite
all you kids in the world humanity
that's the biggest [__] you i've ever
heard gods
just shoulder to shoulder clean across
my step dad down said his name i said i
had a friend and he had a tattoo that
said like
devil's spawn or something dumb as [__]
but is the opposite of that
yeah yeah
opposite of that
um yeah we'll leave it at that my homies
a [__] show
sounds like it
all the names are like that
and i asked them what's your parents
think
well you know it wasn't it wasn't good
but they're my kids i'm like oh my god
dude
is he like a metaphysical type of dude
yeah
not religious in any way though because
my my parents friends
gave their kids names like you know
rainbow sunshine type [__] like that's
something
yeah that's like oh
[Music]
arizona hippie rebel
[__] that [__]
her name's limes and sunshine
yeah that's kind of hard actually yeah
never mind i'll take that
sounds like a flavor i know somebody in
merced that named their child blunt
the boy's name
yeah literally name the kids literally
the first [__] name b-l-u-n-t
the daughter named
buried mary jane named the daughter mary
jane
you're being serious i mean dead serious
my stepbrother my brother martin's one
of his homies
that's a lot when you get to seventh-day
grade it's gonna be a [__] like a
problem not a problem it's gonna be like
awkward awkward you give your kid always
a pre-positioned or pre-disposed to be
like
[__] with
every teacher's gonna look at that kid
like
at least the [__] will
but there's a lot of [__] in the
world
i'm not gonna call some say someone's
wack cause their parents gave him a
[__] controversial last name
but that's a hard one
dub sack damn your first name is dubsack
johnson [__] that sucks
could you imagine it yeah yo this weed
is fire yeah it does
what happened to this episode i don't
know i forgot we were [__] recording
here for a minute i mean yeah it's
getting turned into a facetime
conversation again but it's all right
what's up guys
holy [__]
bad question
oh man you started bringing up minnow
from [__] venus here we go that's
right why don't you introduce next
week's guest real quick
while i find one
all right
so here we go
next week's guest guys
i think is [__] hysterical i saw this
guy on tick tock like eight months ago
and followed i thought he was so [__]
funny
and then our booking agent brings him up
and i go
yes get him right now whenever the [__]
he's got time bring him in
are you ready
and like i said earlier mario are you
sure i don't i don't want to butcher it
and i go
if i say this wrong this name [__] up
excuse me i'm just racist
that's what the joke was before we start
so if they say the name wrong just say
sorry it was due to racism
it's
namish patel i know i said it i just
don't want to [__] it up
and i was like well if you [__] it up
it's okay like well people are going to
be like you [__] his name up like who
cares to say
sorry i'm racist
see this is the [__] we talked about
before they start the show oh yeah it's
just due to my racism yeah sorry just
due to my racism i can't say your name
right
but i did i said it right this
motherfucker's hysterical bro i am very
[__] excited
he's a stand-up comedian i've seen him
he's always in new york
i'm stoked i know you haven't seen him
before we brought him up because you're
like i'm not sure who is and i clicked
on the name and i clicked bro right now
that [__] is funny as hell so
it's about to get more [__] next week
because this fool is one of the people i
can see going hey
say what you want
you normally don't uh you normally don't
react like that oh yeah i don't but when
our booking is like oh that's cool yeah
let's just try but this one was like oh
[__] yeah
because i'm i'm a fan seen him before
dude i've been been seeing him he's
great
um so yeah let's see how bad it gets
next week
let's see how offensive it gets in here
oh
i'm ready for it
we got jibber what's your favorite
episode of podcasting
i was like who who's did you book i
thought you meant like
next guest
underscore jibba underscore okay what's
been your favorite episode thus far as
we close in on season three
i know it sounds wack
but they keep changing
every time we have a different guess i'm
like yo was that the best [__]
episode we've ever done
how many times have we said that i've
been sitting here i mean we say that we
genuinely wholeheartedly say that damn
near every time the guests leave you
gotta remember
me and marty like we're chilling and
hanging out we have the guests coming
they leave the second they're gone me
and him like yeah that was a good one
it's our warehouse so we're just like
sir
look it's it's our space
imagine you know what they look like
high fives
yep it's
yeah i mean we navigated through that
yes fall off the rails or
anything horrible happen so it's genuine
when i say it seems like every time we
the person leaves like yo was that the
best [__] one so far
there's been a lot of those a lot of
those
some of my favorites
was the fki first just because it was
fun yeah it was super fun i agree um
interview styles or interview like
actual interviews i really like the dj
ghost one
i really liked it i know it's recent but
i really [__] liked it got into some
[__] that i know no fans have really
heard too much about just because
his first interview of all time
so
it was awesome it was really really cool
that had different vibes that that
episode just felt different it did
so many people like yo finally it's two
of my favorite people on the [__]
internet are in the same room like yeah
good i'm happy to hear that
that's like the sweet spot of what our
fans want i feel like you know because
we
get into music get into sports get into
comedy get into
anybody but like he is just kind of
represents to me like
the type of episode that really hits the
hardest yeah
where are you we're i know we said that
earlier but spot if i wasn't playing
youtube
we love youtube though man like we
[__] do we put a lot of effort into
making youtube look awesome
excuse me but
what are you gonna do
the [__] it's like the referees are
going uh i see nothing
oh holding
every time we score
holy
five
that doesn't kind of [__] feel like
that oh
we'll get we'll be doing good age
restricted like hey i can get
demonetized i get that but
block it okay [__] you
that's all that's all what are we at
about 2 15. oh [__] garrett oh my god
all right all right what's today
monday
yeah
damn that was fast marty
what the [__] did we even talk about i
don't know that was a [__] blur
but the little nicky version of me today
i can't do the page
classical movie too
yo
what else what else you want to say you
got anything else you want to talk about
today i think that today was just a
ketchup yeah just wanted to say hi guys
we'll see yeah nice little catch-up
episode
we got nemesh booked we got a couple i
don't know i'm just
i'm looking i feel i'm just looking
forward to starting season three finish
this one strong go in there rebuild the
set
make it bigger make it better make it
better put more focus on the like
content of the show
really
build out the segments just grow it make
it better level it up that's how i'm
feeling late night show style mm-hmm
this segment brought to you by so-and-so
so uh
rather get punched in the dick or the
face
or whatever we're gonna ask right after
that stupid-ass question
but you know appreciate you guys
yeah would you rather get punched in the
face or with a glove on or kicked in the
balls
something like that definitely punch
them or without hold on i was trying to
work that around
yeah everything to the
[Laughter]
no
yo these joints lasted a very long time
they did a good job
they did
yeah oh i love this shot
all right i think that's it man i think
i know we're just
let's turn into facetime conversation
because i did forget for a while
i don't know how long but for a while i
did forget that we were filming
once i turn right here it's pretty much
over
like this just gone to me
it's gone
oh oh
leave a like
leave a [__] like on the video
because it helps
leaving likes on the video is like
getting coin or getting rings and sonic
like oh this shit's gonna help we're
getting extra life good [__] it's a
great way to put it that helps us
because you know the boss is over there
[__] ready to knock all our rings out
named youtube
sure that was like we're trying to
impress them with all our coins yeah we
should impress them all our coins and
get them real fast and go quick and jump
but we can't jump
if donkey kong comes in and beats the
[__] out of us yeah without the
reference that was not bad yeah it
wasn't bad it was pretty good and
another thing i packed all my clothes
and i can't find the box with my clothes
so that's why i have a new shirt on
in case you're wondering i didn't put
the shirt up to promote it oh i can't
find my clothes in the sea of boxes that
i moved in last night i just thought it
was funny well it's nice that you have
this [__] you better i don't have a
warehouse yeah just uh let's grab a new
one but it worked perfectly but i want
to be real and be honest i didn't wear
just a remote i wore it because i packed
all my [__] yeah and me and rose were
cutting boxes open before you guys
right before i came to meet you i was
like i'm just gonna wear a new shirt
then [__]
and one of those available
they're probably available now okay
probably
friday yeah future presents
past tense oh that's just inception
movie might as well be playing i'm done
you're gonna have to push trees to
figure out yeah let's go to push streets
on this plane you are currently yeah
these [__] shirts go to
pushtrees.com all right go there and
then you can find stuff shirts and
jokes and jokes and spaghetti spaghetti
spaghetti shipped to your door
all right guys thank you so much for
being here i appreciate you marty what's
up and if you want to hear about more
new stuff being shipped to your door go
watch that new yola video that was a
good one it's called
legal in all 50 states go watch that
video on youtube
legal in all 50 states
the dopeyshop.com we have
hash rosin from hash house
legally being put into our dopest
edibles
then legally shipping them across the
country
i can't wait to try these they're strong
they're real strong i'm gonna i'm gonna
challenge myself at some point oh
it's a narcotic
i wouldn't i would just start and then
you're gonna go oh these are the ones
that hit me these are the kind of
edibles that i need
marty could need a thousand million but
i'm high but i'm not [__] shit-faced
thc from the store doesn't matter
nothing it's marty it's weird but
there's a lot of people out there like
you didn't give me another medicaid like
no you're just marty mm-hmm animals
don't [__] hit him right there's like
mushrooms
it's the irish in him
yeah
i guess so i don't [__] know but yeah
i have faith
dude
i think that's it i think that's it
we'll let you guys go back to what the
[__] you were doing all right i always
got to remember this right now i'm
typing like this
and then after it goes oh my god oh i've
been sitting for two hours [__]
and that's pretty much what's gonna
happen every monday
so thank you guys for being here but
drop that like because it [__]
helps because donkey kong is about to
see see if we're on spotify i could have
said what i was about to say and it
would have made me laugh more uh-huh
that's usually why it's a lot of stupid
[__] that happens it's just to make
myself laugh
but i can't remember what i was gonna
say all the time because i want to tell
you off camera like we're on camera
what i was about to say would have been
[__] incredible
to me noted yeah noted yeah to me how
about this in the edica thomas what did
you mean hey thomas what was this part
like oh so what i was going to say is he
was going to assault him of the
different kind
and we'll stop leave it at that hold
leave it at that
donkey kong
he's got control
let's go
hold on oh the peaches yes
it's the blueberry
that's the blueberry peach and cooked
just like a [__] peach ring
that's one thing you'll always say
say i don't like somebody and they say
they're a grower i'm saying i don't like
a girl see i don't like a grower he's a
[__] dick
i'll always say because i'm not a hater
that guy's a [__] piece of [__] but
his weed is fire
[Music]
i've seen how many times i said that
like
fireweed guy's a [__] [__] but
this week's great
i'll always give you [__] your props
if your shit's right
so even if you don't like me you think
i'm an [__] [__] you if you say that
[__] don't taste great because i marty
if you didn't know me you hit that girl
what the [__] is this yeah
yeah so if you think i'm gonna hassle
it's fine just don't talk [__] about
that until you try it because peaches
the honeydew yeah those are the light
ones yeah the light ones mm-hmm
all right i'll let you guys go back to
what you're doing marty anything else
before we get out of here
thank you guys if it wasn't for you i
wouldn't have did this music so go check
it out 25th thursday spotify drastic
graphics
tell a friend share that [__] motivation
music meant to get you fired the [__] up
i
do it 25th also
oh
oh i think we'll see everybody before
then because rosie rosie has surgery on
the 26th rosie's about to be [__]
bedridden for like a month
i know she's a [__] jaw surgeon what
she's about to go through is like the
fact that i'm scared of bisexual
oh yeah okay yeah i get you i went to
her doctor thing today i'm like oh
you're what that's what you oh my god oh
it's too much
but
he's a specialist
i talked to him less nervous because i'm
[__] nervous um
but yeah we'll be good everything's
gonna be good we're going great
rosie's gonna be fine
i think that's it man i'm gonna get out
of here
i'm gonna get the [__] out of here my
little brother's coming for two weeks
can be hanging out with me while rosie's
hurt he's gonna help while i'm doing
work [__] and vice versa and you can do
some [__] here while i'm over there
it's gonna be good um so yeah i think
that's everything shout out to every
[__] that walked over there i
mean that showed up over there to merced
appreciate you and those [__] group
of dudes i remember signing all the
skateboards they skated there in the
[__] heat shout out to mcnamara park
for putting a skate park in there i
can't believe it has a skatepark i'm
[__] shocked i had no idea i [__]
love to see it um
i think that's it oh yeah yeah
thank you everybody we met at secret
sash
also hey that felt like so long ago i
know
it felt like so long ago man but yes
shout out to secret sesh that was a fun
day that was good [__] you finally got
to come to an event marty's first event
ever even just walking up the street
people pulling up and [__] just stopping
a little side street marty just [__]
screw in hand what oh what's up nice to
meet you
it was cool
i'm gonna have
last thing i got i'm also you got to
react to these tim kennedy videos oh yes
yes i know you told me it was very
controversial figure
uh
ufc former ufc star former green beret
sniper
uh video one him choking out stevo
video two
him demonstrating
uh how do i want to work it's called
making sure it's called making soup
yeah so him demonstrating
how to how to how to take somebody out
and at the end they look like soup
uh-huh but the funniest part of the
video is the duties demonstrating on
because either in like a jiu jitsu class
or some [__]
and
just like and this is where i would kill
you and rip your eye out
but like
i don't know a lot about i mean i know a
lot about tim kennedy but just
he takes there's a lot of people online
that give him a lot of [__] because he
openly talks about being in war
situations
oh oh
yeah there's a i mean like that's the
flag words you just said
maybe you should bleep those maybe
that's what you should believe i'm
already in this edit maybe you should
bleep yeah sir the blanks and the blanks
getting blanked yeah so i wish spotify
would like don't worry guys i know here
come with us i know and as we float like
a video game character getting made
we float just there yeah yeah i like a
creative player yeah
[__] [__] [__] explicit stats going on
yeah explicit
time no time say whatever you want
yeah but anyway just the joy on his face
as he was just like in your like the way
it's weird the way like a jiu jitsu
expert might explain
he's shown you but it's mixed with a
dude that has killed people with his
hands before
where he's like describing he's like no
hey okay all right all right go watch
the video watch the video hey
we're not spotify yet we're not
surprised to find out yet
all right all right yeah we're trying to
wrap this [__] up my bad be safe be safe
out there and i'm like as i dig this is
what you're about to talk about i'll
talk i watch it i'll watch it i watch it
i'll watch it maybe i'll do the reaction
video to it i'll watch it i should
actually yeah um
okay don't get us in trouble that's what
we need to use our app for [__] like
this i know but the app keeps getting
not updated because wakes can't handle
our subscribers so
that's another start and
half of you unsubscribe to the to the
app and it'll work fine
is that something realistic [__] no
hey it's gonna get better i want out
who's gonna go out
no one
the [__] hey everybody goes outside dies
like
then i'm going to stay inside
i don't know it's just like a dumb
scenario you know if it worked it would
work our app would work perfect and it
was less people
i would just step it the [__] up yeah
how about you just do that all right
thanks back end anyway uh yeah we're
we're trying to be part of season three
it's for damn sure going to be part of
the season overall rollout for season
three is better use on to that
[__] dopaziola app we're gonna
get it we're gonna get it situated make
sure to check your emails for
newsletters make sure to follow marty on
instagram which is drastic underscore
graphics
and then on twitter it is marty
underscore made
underscore it marty made it
and then
drastic graphics
make sure you're following subscribed
that sure will be dropping and it helps
and i'm going to be putting out a lot
more
stuff on youtube like
planning the last quarter of this year
going into fall putting up a little [__]
so a lot more stuff right just like
us doing we're doing just so much
hiring [__] we're hiring help
we need it
it doesn't work even though we're about
to get more help we still need more help
for my own personal [__] videos which
is crazy to say
that's a lot of [__]
but it's awesome it's this is fun thank
you guys for being here this is our job
so thanks for making it our job this
week looks amazing through this crap i
keep looking at it through the tutu yeah
oh it looks so cool that's a picture
right there
guys thank you for being here for marty
and i we want to say thank you for
hanging out with us thank you for
listening to ramble for
two hours and 29 [__] minutes are you
serious
it's been a while
thank you guys so much for being here
until next time i'm doug ziola have a
dope ass day oh this has been the dope
as usual podcast if you're driving out
there please be [__] safe
all right and remember to take this away
from earlier
if you don't like some [__]
don't be around them
it's done
all right that's all you gotta say women
are from where we're from california men
are there from there too we're all the
same [__] that book doesn't
make any sense but it does make sense if
you don't take it literal and i was
because cavemen do not have telescopes
the fact that i remembered what we
talked about earlier
i'm a late night show
jimmy kimmel
go home bro
i remember a sentence from earlier
you're [__]
i'ma punch you the [__] table guys
thank you for being here uh have a dope
ass day from lord farquaad and [__]
marty
bye
yo my hair is going crazy bro i feel
like i'm about to ask where [__]
fiona is and [__] um
[Music]